So, jetzt mal schauen, wie es geht.
Ja Leute, da bin ich wieder.
Also laut meiner Garmin-Uhr habe ich heute nur einen Sleep-Score von 56.
Das ist schlecht.
Also, es geht bis 100.
Das lag wahrscheinlich zum größten Teil daran, weil es zu warm war und weil es zu kurz war.
Ich war dabei, ich baue mal meine Arch-VM an und mache Package-Updates, weil Arch, by the way, da geht es bestimmt was.
So, Massive Top-Secret-Passwort, kommt nicht drauf.
Was ist mit meinem Vorschau-Rechner?
Ach ja, ich habe eben gedacht, mein zweiter Computer wäre heute Morgen verreckt.
Weil ich habe das eingeschaltet, ich habe ja hier zwei Monitore an zwei Computer, also nicht zwei Monitore an einem Computer.
Und der Monitor ging auf einmal aus.
Dann ging er wieder an.
Ein paar Sekunden später ging er wieder aus.
Da habe ich gedacht, hä, okay, vielleicht Grafikkarten-Treiber-Update oder sowas, da passiert ja sowas manchmal.
War es aber nicht.
Und auf einmal ging er komplett aus.
Da habe ich schon gedacht, oh shit.
Ding im Arsch.
Könnte man jetzt auch etwas falsch verstehen.
Computer im Arsch, ja.
Und...
Da dachte ich mir so, scheiße, was machst du denn jetzt?
Erstmal ausgeschaltet, eingeschaltet, so die üblichen Sachen, die man so macht, rebooted, hat nichts gebracht.
Scheiße.
Nein, ich meine, ist nicht so schlimm.
Haupt-Main-Computer geht, ja, kein Problem.
Und da habe ich mir schon gedacht, okay, was machst du?
Probierst du mal die Onboard-Grafikkarte aus, anstatt die Nvidia-Grafikkarte, die da drin ist.
Was machst du jetzt?
Und dann war der Fehler tatsächlich mit der simpelsten Maßnahme, die es hätte sein können, gefixt.
Der HDMI-Stecker ist rausgerutscht über die Jahre.
Ich habe jetzt einfach den Stecker richtig wieder reingesteckt und jetzt geht alles.
Es war also gar nichts kaputt.
Es war ein sehr langweiliges Problem.
Ist mir aber ganz recht besser, als dass mein zweiter PC kaputt ist.
Lieber easy-to-fix-ene Probleme, als schwer-to-fix-ene Probleme und der Rechner ist dann kaputt am Ende.
Besser VGA-Nutz, auch DVI.
DVI hat auch ein Festschraube-Ding.
Und Display-Port?
Display-Port?
Display-Port hat auch diese, wie nennt man das?
Widerhaken.
Das ist natürlich ein HDMI-Stecker.
Der hat sowas nicht.
Das ist eh ganz weird-champiger Monitor.
Das ist ein uralter Monitor von ISO, den ich da dran habe am zweiten Rechner.
Ein 24-Zoll-Monitor.
Den habe ich immer noch.
Ich hatte zwischenzeitlich schon ganz viele andere Monitore.
Aber den habe ich immer noch und den werde ich auch behalten, weil den habe ich einmal kalibriert mit so einem Ding.
Ich weiß nicht, ob ihr das kennt, aber da gibt es so Teile, die hängt man vor den Monitor.
Da gibt es so Geräte.
Ja, sowas hier, genau.
Guckt, da gibt es so Geräte.
Die hängt man vor den Monitor.
Das sieht dann genauso aus wie hier.
Und dann startet man so eine Kalibrierungssoftware.
Die zeigt dann blau, rot, grün, irgendwelche Sachen auf dem Monitor.
Das Ding misst, wie genau das jetzt blau ist und wie genau das jetzt grün ist.
Und dann kannst du entweder an den Monitorreglern rumspielen.
Bis es passt, oder du lässt dir ein Farbprofil kreieren und dieses Farbprofil lädst du dann in deinem Betriebssystem.
Dann geht das auch.
Und seit ich den Monitor mal kalibriert habe, habe ich, ich habe den jetzt schon, der ist über zehn Jahre alt, das ist das uralte Monitor.
Aber wenn ich mal wirklich irgendwas brauche, wo die Farbdarstellung so mehr oder weniger original ist, dann mache ich das immer auf dem zweiten Rechner an diesem Monitor.
Ja, da brauche ich kein 120, 240 Hertz oder sonst was.
Das ist ein ganz normaler Full-HD, ich weiß nicht gerade, ob das so Full-HD ist.
Ja, ich glaube, ganz normaler, ja doch, doch, ich denke 16 zu 9.
Ganz normaler Full-HD 60 Hertz Monitor.
Nichts tolles, aber der ist halt kalibriert.
Und ISO macht ja allgemein ganz gescheite Monitore.
Deswegen habe ich da die Sensor-Updates.
Was, was sagt?
Hier, was sagen die Jetbrains-Dinger, müssen die auch geupdatet werden?
Oh, guck mal, Rider, gibt es jetzt was Neues?
Gibt es, was gibt es bei Rider Neues?
.NET 9 wird supportet.
Full-Line-Code-Completion für C++.
Ja, für C++, ich glaube nicht, dass das Ding checkt wie C++, weil niemand checkt C++.
Ja, dann ist das super wichtig.
Es kommt selten vor, dass ich irgendwas brauche, wo ich einen kalibrierten Monitor brauche, ja.
Das ist, das kommt so selten vor, dass ich mich jetzt gar nicht mehr daran erinnern kann, wann das mal der Fall war.
Für Videos machen ist es an sich nicht verkehrt, wenn man dann Videos macht auf YouTube.
Für Videos an sich ist es nicht verkehrt, weil man dann so eine, so eine, so eine Base sagt, also, okay, darin sieht es gut aus, dann wird es wahrscheinlich mit den meisten anderen Monitor-Settings auch gut ausschauen.
Ich habe, ich habe jetzt ein halbes Jahr nichts mehr auf YouTube gemacht, keck, wait, Leute.
.NET 9 wird supportet.
Ja, ich habe ich gerade so einen Motivations-Durchhänger, was das angeht, ohne erkennbaren Grund, weil es hat sich eigentlich nichts geändert.
Und es ist auch nicht so, als wüsste ich nicht, was ich erzählen soll.
Ich habe eine ganz lange Liste, die habe ich seit Jahren schon, ich weiß, die wird, die wird auch immer länger, ne, mit Zeug.
Aber es gibt so ein paar offensichtlich naheliegende Sachen, wie zum Beispiel, dass ich eigentlich gesagt habe, erstens, ich zeige euch mal meine Bewerbung, das habe ich schon vor über einem Jahr gesagt, ja.
Dann auch Gehaltsentwicklung und wie es jetzt im neuen Job ist, also ein paar Sachen, so als Update zu den letzten.
Videos, wo ich gesagt hab, die mach ich. Hab ich aber nie
gemacht. Aber man kennt's ja. Man kennt's
ja. Okay.
Reboot. Leute, ich
hab mich bei 1, 2, 3, 4, 5, 6 verschrieben.
Wie schlecht kann
man sein? Oh nein.
Ich hab mein Passwort geleakt, Leute.
Seid ihr schon
drin jetzt?
Jetzt ist es raus.
Mein Passwort ist 1, 2, 3, 4, 5, 6.
Shit.
Jetzt vorbei. So.
Ich glaube, das passt so.
So. Entspannung, eine Runde
AskIquarium. Exzellent.
Ich sag immer,
1, 2, 3, 4, 5, 6 kann kein
schlechtes Passwort sein, weil es ist
das meistverbreitete Passwort auf der Welt.
Und wie kann was so verbreitetes
schlecht sein?
Das würden ja nicht so viele machen, wenn es nichts taugen würde.
So. Und Chat. Was hab ich
verpasst diese Woche?
Es gibt ja leider immer noch
keine gescheite Wochenzusammenfassung bei Heise.
Da hätte ich gesagt, lass mal kurz gucken,
was es so für News gab.
Windows Update legt erneut Linux
zu lahm. Macht Microsoft
da immer. Na gut, was sie
machen, ist klar. Die gehen Leuten,
die Alternativen verwenden, absichtlich auf
den Sack.
Microsoft bringt FAT32
zurück. Na endlich.
Da hat die Welt drauf gewartet.
Auf dem Discord
gibt es die krasse News. Tatsächlich.
Ich war gestern
auf dem Discord. Ich hab nichts gesehen.
Was gibt es denn da für krasse News?
Außer, dass ich müde bin.
Weil ich nur einen
Sleep-Score von
56 hab.
Das wusste ich tatsächlich
nicht. Ich hab mir aber sowas
gedacht, weil
ich hab das Video von
Fireship gesehen.
Ich hab das nicht das
Video gesehen, wie man hier sieht.
Ich hab aber gesehen, dass Fireship ein Video
gemacht hat. Da bin ich mal gespannt.
Das Video gucken wir uns dann gleich an.
Das hab ich... Die News
hab ich gelesen. Ja. Die News
hab ich gelesen.
Ich weiß nicht mehr wo.
Zumindest hab ich die News gelesen,
dass
eine Familie, ich hoffe ich krieg das jetzt auch richtig
zusammen. Eine Familie
hat irgendeinen Disney-Freizeitpark
besucht.
Und
haben da irgendwie eine Lebensmittelvergiftung gekriegt
oder so.
Und ich bin mir nicht ganz sicher, ob so gar nicht
einer gestorben ist dabei.
Durch die Lebensmittelvergiftung.
Und
jetzt will die Familie Disney
verklagen.
Aber Disney sagt,
ihr könnt uns gar nicht verklagen.
Ja, okay.
Im Detail weiß ich's nicht.
Aber Disney hat gesagt,
Disney sagt, ihr könnt uns nicht
dafür verklagen, dass jemand
bei uns im Freizeitpark gestorben ist, weil
ihr habt ja mal vor ein paar Jahren
ein Disney Plus Abo abgeschlossen.
Und in dem Disney Plus
Abo, in den AGBs
steht drinnen, dass man Disney nicht
mehr verklagen kann.
Das ist, ich weiß nicht, das ist auf der
einen Seite die
die traurigste und auf der
anderen Seite die
Most-Kekona-Sache überhaupt, ja.
Wobei ich mir nicht mal
vorstellen kann, dass die, ich kann mir noch nicht mal
vorstellen, dass die sogar bei den Amis damit durchkommen.
Das glaube ich nicht.
Disney wird wahrscheinlich jetzt versuchen, das ist meine
Vermutung, das nach Möglichkeit
mit möglichst viel Kohle ausgerichtet
zu klären. So wie
sowas ja oftmals probiert wird.
So nach dem Motto, willst du nicht
drei, vier Millionen haben und dann lässt
du das, weil das juckt Disney
nicht.
Ja. Also da sieht man mal,
dass die meisten dieser super
großen Unternehmen voll für
den Arsch sind.
Das ist jetzt ja wirklich nichts Neues.
Deswegen, und das ist auch der
Grund, war sogar nur ein Probe-Abo, ja.
Das ist auch der Grund, warum ich immer sage,
dass es sich überhaupt
nicht lohnt, oder
eigentlich total dumm ist,
irgendwas Hardcore zu fanboyen.
Weil die Ultra-Fanboys
werden am meisten
ausgenommen, das ist das Erste. Also die werden
schon am meisten verarscht.
Und wenn man wirklich irgendwas ist,
wird weder der, was weiß ich,
der Microsoft-Chef oder der Sony-Chef
oder der Disney-Chef oder irgendjemand sagen,
ach ja, das war
jetzt ja ein zehn Jahre langer
richtiger Hardcore-Sony-Fanboy,
der uns bei jedem Scheiß online
verteidigt hat.
Da sind wir jetzt mal nett zu dem.
Nee, nee, nee, das ist denen vollkommen egal.
Durch
ultra-sinnloses Fanboyen
verliert man eigentlich nur...
Ja, ich hab alle Updates gemacht. Irgendwie hab ich
so ein Kurzzeitgedächtnis
nicht mehr existent.
Klar hab ich
Updates gemacht, deswegen hab ich die VRB auch gestartet.
Also bei den Amis kannst du
das machen, bei uns kannst du das wahrscheinlich
auch reinschreiben, wobei ich mir relativ sicher
bin, dass es bei uns so nicht wirksam ist.
Würde ich jetzt mal vermuten. Ich hoffe, dass das
bei uns besser ist.
Insgesamt, ich
kann mir auch nicht vorstellen, dass die bei den Amis
da durchkommen. Aber ich bin mal
gespannt, was da rauskommt.
Ja, lass uns mal schauen,
was auf GitHub trendet.
Die Weekly-Shithub-Trends.
Oh Mensch, muss
rausgucken. Ach ja, übrigens.
Dieses
Wochenende wird wieder fett Stonks gemacht.
Also nicht Stonks
in Aktienform.
Die... Was machen eigentlich meine...
Lass mich mal kurz gucken.
Oh, ich hab einen Reminder gerade bekommen
auf meinem iPhone, dass ich
endlich mal BIOS flashen soll.
Weil ich hab einen 13.900k,
der von dieser ganzen Internetgeschichte betroffen
ist. Und ich wollte eine Woche nach dem
BIOS-Release warten, weil ich mir
nicht sicher war, ob so ein Beta-BIOS ist.
Aber wenn es bis da jetzt keine Probleme
gab,
dann werde ich das wahrscheinlich heute
flashen. Was mich beim BIOS-Flashen ein bisschen
nervt, ist, dass die Settings verloren gehen.
Da muss ich im Vorfeld erstmal gucken, was hab ich eigentlich
alles eingestellt.
Okay, lass mal kurz gucken.
Oh, nice.
Die Stonks waren wieder besser.
Nicht so Müll wie die letzten...
Die Stonks sind wieder... Alter,
Big Brain Time. Hat sich mal wieder...
Es hat sich mal wieder gelohnt, Leute.
Es hat sich mal wieder gelohnt, ja.
Naja, also nicht so krass wie vor...
Nicht so krass wie 2021.
Aber immer noch
sehr ordentlich.
Nice.
Also,
ich hab
vor zwei Wochen, oder wann war das hier?
5. August.
5. August hab ich ein bisschen
ETF-Sachen nachgekauft.
Weil da ist das ja mal
eine Woche so richtig heftig gefallen.
Das ist hier runtergegangen von
auf 112.
Und da hab ich
nochmal gekauft.
Jetzt geht die gleich wieder hoch.
Und was ist? Bäm!
Diese Woche...
Moment, ich muss so gucken.
Jetzt sind wir bei 121 wieder. Nice.
Aber der beste Big Brain Move
war immer noch, wobei das weniger
Big Brain war, sondern tatsächlich ein bisschen Glück
und Hoffen.
Als das in der Ukraine losging
und das
ganz weit unten war,
hab ich 30.000 Euro
ETF nachgekauft.
Und seitdem
ist das um
48% wieder gestiegen.
Sehr nice.
Exzellent.
Es wird natürlich nicht immer so sein.
Und wirklich was davon hat man natürlich
auch erst, wenn man es verkauft.
Ich verkaufe das für die nächsten 20 Jahre aber nicht.
Aber nice. Sehr schön.
So muss das sein.
Ja.
Ich mein, alle waren besser als
auf dem Konto
rumliegen lassen.
Denkst du nicht, das ist ein World ETF?
Mehr verteilt kann es doch gar nicht sein.
Einfach kaufen, bevor es steigt.
Pfeifert. Ja, immer, immer beste Idee.
Man weiß es ja auch immer im Voraus.
Vier Stunden. Was war?
Was hast du vier Stunden in den Bios gemacht?
Was kann man in vier Stunden kannst du jedes Biosetting
einmal ein und einmal ausschalten und rebooten?
Was ich hoffe, es gibt in meinem Bios irgend so einen Diff,
wo man sich anzeigen lassen kann, was man eigentlich alles geändert hat,
weil das weiß ich jetzt nicht mehr.
Ah, Underworld.
Ja, Underworld. Ich habe eigentlich gar nichts geändert an der CPU.
Ich glaube, das Einzige, was ich eingeschaltet habe,
ist Multicore-Enhancement und das war's.
Ich habe noch nicht mal meinen übertaktbaren RAM übertaktet.
Ach ja, was ich eigentlich sagen wollte.
Ja, dieses Wochenende wird wieder fett Stonks mit quasi passiven Einkommen generiert,
weil ich habe wieder Rufbereitschaft das ganze Wochenende.
Und bis jetzt war gar nichts.
Und ich hoffe, dass auch heute und heute Nacht,
gar nichts ist und es heißt im Endeffekt,
ich kriege wieder Fettkohle für gar nichts.
Das ist sehr nice.
So selten, wie was ist, wobei so selten ist gar nichts.
Also es ist schon selten was, aber nicht so, dass man sagen kann, es ist nie was.
Ja, ich wurde tatsächlich jetzt schon öfters mal in letzter Zeit angerufen.
Bereitschaftstechnisch.
Aber die bezahlen so viel Geld dafür, dass man einfach nur Bereitschaft macht.
Da ist mir das.
Ich würde, ich würde jeden Tag, ich würde jede Nacht, ja, würde ich,
würde ich Bereitschaft machen.
Das ist mir bei mir egal.
Also es kann sein, dass während dem Stream das Handy klingelt
oder unser Monitoring System irgendwelche Meldungen schickt.
So hier Achtung kaputt, du musst mal gucken.
Okay, gut, das sollte ich wahrscheinlich.
Das sollte ja gut, denn ich habe es ja schon gespeichert.
Ich muss mal gucken.
So viel habe ich nicht eingestellt, mein Bios.
Aber ich sollte das mal updaten.
Auch wenn ich aktuell mein Rechner so gut wie gar nicht großartig auslaste,
will ich trotzdem nicht.
Dass er in einem Jahr anfängt, instabil zu werden.
Auf der anderen Seite.
Wisst ihr, was ich mir auch überlegt habe?
Ich werde das nicht machen.
Ich sage es, ich sage es nur mal.
Was ich mir auch überlegt habe.
Das letzte Mal habe ich ja zwei Jahre überlegt, ob ich mir mindestens zwei Jahre überlegt,
ob ich mir nicht endlich mal einen neuen Rechner kaufen sollte.
Also als ich den letzten noch hatte.
Da habe ich überlegt Okay, sollte ich mir eine Ryzen Kiste kaufen?
Ach nee, dann doch wieder nicht.
Jetzt bald kommt die neue Ryzen Generation sein.
Ah nee, doch wieder nicht.
So und nach.
Nach über fünf Jahren habe ich mir dann endlich einen neuen Rechner gekauft.
Natürlich kein billigen, schon gescheiten Rechner.
Also der hier, wo ich auf dem jetzt gerade bin.
Und also ich habe überlegt, vielleicht sollte ich das Update nicht einspielen, dass mein
Rechner nach drei Jahren kaputt geht, dass ich mir nicht mehr so viel Gedanken machen
muss, ob ich mir jetzt endlich einen neuen Rechner kaufen soll oder nicht.
Dass die Intel CPU einfach verreckt nach drei Jahren.
Und.
Und dann muss ich mir einen neuen Rechner kaufen und dann kaufe ich mir endlich einen AMD Rechner.
Aber ich glaube, das ist nicht die.
Nicht die schlauste Variante.
Ich glaube, die schlauste Variante ist Bios Update installieren und Gutes.
Ja, das war aber, weil die Haupt.
Also das waren ja oftmals Leute, die ihren Rechner richtig fett ausgelastet haben.
Ich habe meinen Rechner schon zwei Jahre jetzt und habe den selten viel ausgelastet.
Und der macht noch überhaupt keine Probleme.
Das heißt nichts, nicht, dass es nicht in zwei Wochen anfangen kann oder so.
So, dann lasst uns mal gucken, was diese Woche auf ShitHub so trendet.
Realtime Face Swap.
Ja, das brauchen wir nicht.
AI, AI, AI, AI, AI.
Nee, nicht wirklich.
Bootstrap ist nicht.
Moment.
Warum ist es nur heute?
Nee.
Warum trendet Bootstrap?
Ausgerechnet Bootstrap?
Gab es da eine neue Version oder sowas?
Bootstrap ist so der Oldschool Kram, was CSS angeht, ohne Ende.
Nee, nee.
Hä, warum trendet Bootstrap ausgerechnet Bootstrap jetzt?
Kann mir das irgendjemand sinnig erklären?
By the way, wir können froh sein, dass Bootstrap mit Twitter nichts mehr zu tun hat.
Das TW steht ja wahrscheinlich noch für Twitter.
Dass Bootstrap mit Twitter nichts mehr zu tun hat, weil Bootstrap hätte Elon bestimmt eingestellt mittlerweile.
Wenn das noch Teile von Twitter gewesen wären.
Ja, gut.
Keine Ahnung, warum ausgerechnet Bootstrap auf einmal massig Sterne bekommt.
Kaffee, ja.
Ich muss meinen Tee auch mal leer trinken, ja.
Letzte Woche ein neues Bootstrap-Projekt gestartet.
Vielleicht liegt es an mir, dass es trendet.
Bestimmt.
Hast du deine GitHub-Like-Bots angeschmissen?
Easy Spoder.
China-Chinesen-Kram.
Ich habe absolut keine Ahnung, was es sein soll von der Projektbeschreibung.
What the f...
Okay, Leute.
Kein blassen Schimmer.
Irgendein Dart-Ding.
Ich verstehe nicht, was das ist.
Anhand der Beschreibung und anhand der Bilder auch nicht.
AI, AI.
Nicht AI.
Servo.
War Servo nicht die CSS-Geschichte in Rust?
IC++.
AI.
Hast du den neuen Raspberry Pi Pico gesehen?
Nee.
Ist das irgendwie erwähnenswert?
Ja.
Ist der neue Raspberry Pi Pico für zwei...
Aha.
Wahlweise ARM-Cores oder RISC.
Läuft dann auf dem Pico auch Linux, wenn es ARM-Cores...
Nee, nee, oder?
Ich meine, Linux kann auf manchen Taschenrechnern laufen.
Das ist nicht ausgeschlossen.
Okay, nee.
Es bleibt ein reiner Microcontroller.
Also quasi...
Also im Prinzip alles wie gehabt.
Ja.
Ganz ehrlich?
Ich verstehe den...
Hat das jetzt mittlerweile WiFi standardmäßig?
Nee.
Ganz ehrlich, ich verstehe den Sinn dieses Dings nicht.
Also doch, ich verstehe den Sinn dieses Dings schon.
Falsch ausgedrückt.
Ich verstehe aber nicht, warum ich den verwenden würde.
Weil ich kann einfach einen ESP32 verwenden.
Der ist...
In allen Belangen...
Vermutlich zumindest.
Mir fällt jetzt nichts Gegenteiliges ein.
In allen Belangen besser.
Hat WiFi.
Und ich kenne mich damit aus.
Also in welchen...
Okay.
Wann würde ich einen Raspberry Pi Pico verwenden?
Ich habe hier sogar noch welche...
Welche gekauft, als die neu waren.
Wann würde ich einen Raspberry Pi Pico verwenden, wenn ich...
Versus einen ESP32...
Mir fällt jetzt kein...
Kein Grund ein.
Für 5 Euro kann es durchaus sein.
Ich weiß nicht, was der Zero...
Das ist der Wireless Zero.
Der dürfte wahrscheinlich ein bisschen teurer sein als 5 Euro.
Also keine Ahnung.
Mich interessiert es nur wirklich...
Aus irgendwelchen Gründen trenne ich den Bootstrap.
Okay.
Ich muss das hier vorne zu machen.
Sobald ich das hier aufmache, rege ich mich wieder auf.
Weg damit.
Es war...
Es war ja sehr unspektakulär, was trendet, oder?
Okay.
Dann lass uns mal...
Lass uns mal kurz gucken, ob in .NET noch irgendwas Interessantes trendet.
Da trendet aber eigentlich nie was Interessantes.
Keine Ahnung, was das ist.
Beta Genshin Impact.
Okay.
Nächstes spannendes...
Mini Excel.
Ach nee.
Okay.
Das ist .NET Library, um Excel Sachen zu...
Zu bearbeiten.
Okay.
Das Sommerloch ist überall...
Warum...
Okay.
Elf Sterne.
Elf Sterne lasse ich mir gefallen.
Ich verstehe...
Ich...
Jedes Mal, wenn ich Maui sehe, verstehe ich nicht, warum das überhaupt trenden sollte.
Maui ist echt sowas, wo ich jeden Tag darauf warte, dass Microsoft den Blogpost raushaut,
dass es eingestellt wird.
So.
Dann lasst uns doch mal das Video...
Jetzt haben wir ja gerade schon dabei...
Lasst uns mal das Video angucken, was denn jetzt mit kim.com ist.
Das interessiert mich.
Kim.com.
He's been called the titan of terabytes.
The El Chapo...
Kim.com.
He's been called the titan of terabytes.
The El Chapo of file sharing.
And the king of copyright infringement.
If you don't know him, he's a mega-hacker and mega-businessman...
Moment!
Sekunde.
Sekunde, Leute.
Wo wir gerade dabei sind...
Zumindest der Anfang muss mal kurz sein, okay?
It's so fast.
Super cringe, ja.
Die wussten halt überhaupt nicht, was sie da in die Kamera schwätzen, ey.
Her...
He, I like mega-uploads.
I like mega-uploads.
Okay.
Dann schauen wir mal, was aus ihm jetzt wird.
... of copyright infringement.
If you don't know him, he's a mega-hacker and mega-businessman, who ran a digital empire
called Mega in the early 2000s.
Oh...
of daily active users and brought in
over 175 million in revenue.
The website was brilliant, both for its
user-friendly front-end UI and distributed
back-end that allowed people to share
massive files around the world, which was
almost unheard of at the time. There was just
one problem. The website made its money by
selling ads, and those ads were served
primarily on pirated material,
like movies, music, and software.
In 2012, the FBI shut down Mega Upload
and raided Kim's mansion in New Zealand.
But for the last decade, he's managed
to avoid extradition to the United States
and has remained a high-profile rich dude.
That is until yesterday, when a New Zealand
judge ruled that he could be handed over to the United
States to be tried as a pirate.
In today's video, we'll look at the mega-crazy
story of Kim.com and the technical
features behind Mega Upload. It is
August 15th, 2024, and you're
watching The Code Report.
Da kann man sich jetzt streiten, ob man da dafür ist,
dass der ausgeliefert wird oder nicht.
Man könnte ja sagen,
er hat ja keinem wirklich was getan, ne?
Also zumindest nicht mit Mega Upload.
Kim Schmitz is a German...
Außer, dass es viele Leute wahrscheinlich
ordentlich Kohle gekostet hat.
Da sind wir aber auch wieder bei dem Punkt,
ist ein, das sagt ja die
Content...
Industrie,
die Media-Industrie gerne.
Da kann man sich aber schon lange drüber streiten,
und zwar
ist ein illegal
gedownloadeter Film
oder irgendwie Musik
wirklich ein
entgangener Kauf.
Das ist halt so ein Ding,
da wird ja schon lange drüber diskutiert.
Ich bin der Meinung, das stimmt nicht,
weil viele Leute, die sich was runterladen,
hätten sich das im Leben nicht gekauft.
Umgedreht würde ich sogar sagen, manche Leute kaufen
sich was, nachdem sie sich mal Probe angeguckt
haben oder Probe angehört haben.
Insgesamt ist es höchstwahrscheinlich
trotzdem ein Minusgeschäft für die Content-Hersteller.
Das ist ziemlich basiert, aber 1994
wurde er verhaftet, um gehandelt zu werden,
für gehandelte Telefonnummern, dann verhaftet,
um mehr Gehörsvermögen zu verursachen,
aber er hat nie einen bedeutenden Gehörsabschluss gemacht,
weil der Gericht es zu einer jüdischen Verrücktheit
gezwungen hat.
Er hat dann seine Glück weitergepumpt,
2001, als er ein Bankrupt-Website
bei Let'sBuyIt.com gekauft hat,
während der Dotcom-Krasse.
Er hat allen gesagt, er würde ein paar Dosen Geld
in sie pumpen, und nachdem die Stärke
hochgegangen ist, hat er es für einen kurzen Profit gedumpft.
Er hat Ruckpools pumpen und dumpfen gemacht,
bevor sie cool waren. Er hat versucht, in Thailand zu kommen
und seine eigene Todesfälle zu verfolgen, aber wiederum
wurde er verhaftet und wiederum eine
verabschiedete Angelegenheit erhielt.
Trotz seiner Vergewaltigungen emigrierte er
schließlich in Neuseeland auf eine Investoren-Visa,
und das bringt uns zu 2005
und dem Wachstum des Mega-Empires von Kim.
Es war eine Kollektion von Websites, die alles
von Payment-Prozessionen bis zur
Philanthropie machten, aber ihre Haupt-Service war
File-Uploads.
Was? Mega-Pay? Das gab es?
... von Payment-Prozessionen bis zur
Philanthropie, aber ihre Haupt-Service waren
File-Uploads, wie ein Prekursor
zu Dropbox oder Google Drive.
Seine html-basierte UI war schneller und einfacher
als iTunes, aber vor allem
ermöglichte es jemandem, extrem große
File zu veröffentlichen. Diese Veröffentlichungen
konnten aufgehoben und aufgehoben werden.
... und jeder Download
würde einen einzigen Link erzeugen, der mit
deinen Freunden geteilt werden könnte. Und sie konnten
auf einem massiven Niveau mit Techniken wie
File-Deduplikation, wo ein Hash für ein
File erzeugt wird, also wenn man versucht,
den selben Piraten-Seinfeld-Episode zweimal zu
veröffentlichen, nimmt es nur den Raum
eines Files. Mega hatte auch einen bestimmten Niveau
von Sicherheits- und Encryption, um User-Daten zu schützen,
aber es war nicht völlig anonym, und nach dem
Behandlung der Dauer, hat sich keiner
der User zurückgezogen, obwohl Mega Upload
weiterhin als Mega lebt. Heutzutage benutzt
Mega Zero-Knowledge-Encryption, wo...
Ja, Mega hat er aber ja verkauft an irgendwelche
Chinesen.
Das hat er, glaube ich, mit ihm gar nichts mehr zu tun.
... es wird auf dem Klienten
und auf dem Server gekryptert, sodass
kein Dritterpartner, auch Mega, weiß, was
du veröffentlichst. Was absolut genius war,
ist, dass Mega Upload ein Affiliate-Programm
hatte, das User beitragte, um Downloads zu generieren,
was schließlich in Mega-Accounting
für 4% oder mehr
globaler Internet-Traffic, und
Räder voller Geld für Kim.
Leider kam das Party 2012 zu einem Schluss,
als der Website geschlossen wurde,
die Server wurden gesiegt, und Kims
New-Zealand-Maschinen wurden geratet. Sie haben alles genommen,
auch sein Toyota Vellfire. Nun, Uncle Sam
hat versucht, seine Hände an ihm zu bringen,
aber New-Zealand hat den Search-Warrant
verletzt und ihn illegal gespioniert, und
seine Ausstattung hat mehrere Male gedauert.
Aber jetzt sieht es so aus, als ob die Wälder
geschlossen sind, und die Vereinigten Staaten
haben das Grünlicht, um ihn hinzubekommen.
Letztes Jahr wurden zwei ehemalige Mega-Upload-Exekuten verhaftet,
und der echte Typ, den sie ein Beispiel machen möchten, ist
Kim.com. Sie sagen, er kostet der Unternehmensindustrie
500 Millionen Dollar.
Ja, da habe ich halt, da habe ich halt so meine
Zweifel, wer das wieder irgendwie
ausgerechnet hat.
500 Millionen Dollar.
Ich meine, außerdem, was sind 500 Millionen
für die?
Ich meine, das ist viel Kohle, ne? Aber...
...vielfältige philosophische
Diskussionen hier zu haben, wie ist
Piraten tatsächlich ein Verbrechen? Ist Privaten
ein grundlegendes Recht für die Menschen auf der Internetseite?
Und sollen Cloud-Providern Daten erhalten und
das ist... Das ist eine sehr philosophische Frage,
ob das Liebstahl ist, weil die Sachen sind ja da
immer noch da.
Ja, ist das so?
Ist Signal geblockt in
Russland?
Moment, wer sagt das?
Roskomnat...
What?
Okay, alles, alles klar.
...Signal.
One thing's for sure, though.
Kim.com won't go to jail without
a Mega-Fighter.
Was?
Okay, alles, alles klar.
...Signal.
Kim.com won't go to jail without a Mega-Fighter.
This has been the Code Report. Thanks for watching
and I will see you in the next one.
Da bin ich mal gespannt, was da rauskommt.
Wusstet ihr, dass
Kim.com auch Weltranglisten
oder Highscore
Listen erster war
in Modern Warfare 3?
Im originalen Modern Warfare 3?
...
...vor...
...vor 12 Jahren.
Moment, wie heißt der?
Mega-Racer.
...
Das stimmt übrigens nicht.
Das ist Modern Warfare 3 gewesen.
Nicht aus
2023.
Ja, richtig Sadgear, ne?
Find ich auch.
Jetzt, Leute, jetzt wo ich hier grad die ganzen
Cat-Videos sehe,
ich wollte euch noch was zeigen, hab ich nämlich
bei mir hier in den News gelesen.
Und zwar ein Tierheim bei uns hier in der Nähe.
Dort wurde eine Katze abgegeben
mit zwei gebrochenen Vorderbeinen.
Kater Semi.
Ja, genau.
Der hat zwei gebrochene Beine
und das kostet
2000 Euro
die Beine zu fixen.
Wenn jemand von euch,
ich poste das mal in den Chat,
ein Herz für Semi hat,
kann er sich ja überlegen, ob er sich daran beteiligen möchte.
Ich würd mal sagen,
jeder Euro hilft.
Ich hab noch nix gespendet.
Ich hab den E-Mail geschrieben,
wie viel noch fehlt.
Und mein Plan ist,
wenn die drauf antworten
und, keine Ahnung, dann
irgendwie am Dienstag oder so sagen, es fehlen noch
800 Euro oder so,
dann überweis ich das denen,
dass Semi operiert werden kann.
Irgendwas
Sinnvolles muss ich ja mit meiner Kohle auch mal machen.
Ja, Semi kann ich
richtig laufen, weil er seine...
beide Vorderbeine...
Hier, vorne rechts das Bein,
hinten links...
Ich hab das mal in den Chat gepostet.
Gucken, dass Semi wieder laufen kann demnächst.
Und wenn ich schon mal hier on bin
und ein paar Leute zugucken,
nicht verkehrt,
mal was Sinnvolles hier,
meine Kohle in was Sinnvolles zu stecken.
Ihr kennt mich ja,
ich spende generell lieber für Tierheime
und Katzenoperationen und sonst was,
als für Menschen.
Kann jeder mit seiner Kohle machen,
ich soll ihr nicht vorschreiben,
was ihr machen sollt.
Aber mir sieht's halt so aus.
Hast du eigentlich
irgendwelche Linus-Zertifikate?
Nein, hab ich nicht.
Ich hab gar nichts an Zertifikaten.
Ich hab mal ein CCNA
gemacht, vor Urzeiten.
Das ist richtig lange her.
Deswegen kenn ich noch so ein paar Sachen von Cisco,
aber ein CCNA ist wirklich ja
die idiotensicherste
Cisco...
Das idiotensicherste
Cisco-Zertifikat, was man machen kann.
Das ist jetzt nicht
super ultra
easy, aber es ist schon easy.
Deswegen weiß ich
zumindest noch ein paar Sachen,
was Cisco-Administration angeht.
Ich weiß, dass man am Anfang
EN eingeben muss,
da kann ich mich noch dran erinnern.
Und dass man, wenn man die Config speichern will,
dass man irgendwie was machen muss.
Copy
Running Start oder irgendwie sowas.
Kann ich mich auch noch dran erinnern.
Dass man
Ports bei Cisco nicht hoch fährt,
sondern nicht runter fährt.
Und dass man mit Fragezeichen
Shell Completion macht.
Ich glaub, das ist so ziemlich alles,
was ich mir vom CCNA gemerkt hab.
Mehr weiß ich nicht mehr.
Jemand von euch
auch CCNA-Enjoyer?
Ich weiß, relativ viele Leute haben das.
Hat jemand von euch auch?
Hat auch mal ein CCNA gemacht?
Ja, so so, okay.
Ich glaube,
ich glaube, dass das sogar
relativ viele haben.
Ansonsten
hab ich noch ein paar
Azure-Kurse gemacht,
wo es dann so ein, kann man nicht mal
Zertifikat nennen, so ein Ding gibt,
dass man es halt gemacht hat.
Das war's.
Ich persönlich bin eh der Meinung,
dass dieses ganze
Zertifikats-Ökosystem ein
sich selbst erhaltende
Gelddruck-Maschine ist,
die eigentlich keiner braucht.
Du hast ein
CISSP gemacht.
Das weiß ich nicht,
was es ist. Ist es Storage?
Also,
früher gab es,
früher gab es, früher, also
zu Zeiten, wo ich CCNA gemacht hab,
war die höchste Cisco
Aus-, äh, nicht Auszeichnung,
höchste Cisco Zertifikat,
was man machen konnte,
Internet Engineer oder wie das hieß.
Cisco Certified Internet Engineer,
IAE oder so, gab so was mal.
Und ansonsten,
keine Ahnung,
ich beschäftige mich mit, mit diesem
Zertifikats,
ähm, Landscape auch nicht wirklich.
Ich, wie gesagt, ich halte das
für ein sich so,
zumindest ein sich, versuchen
sich selbst zu erhalten, das so
Kreislauf-Ökosystem,
wo sie sich untereinander
immer möglichst viel Geld
zuschustern.
Lpick 1, der Lpick 1,
Lpick 1 hab ich mal so ne Testprüfung gemacht,
witzigerweise, ja, das, äh, ich hab nie
nen Lpick 1 fertig gemacht,
aber ich hab mal so ne Probeprüfung gemacht,
da muss ich sagen, auch wenn man
sich jahrelang schon mit Linux
beschäftigt, Lpick gab es
die ein oder anderen Fragen damals,
wo ich mir auch überlegt hab, alter, what, ey,
woher soll man das ausm Kopf
wissen, ja?
Ich kann euch leider kein Beispiel
mal sagen. Also, es war,
eigentlich sollte man denken, easy as
fuck, war es aber nicht.
Aha.
Wie gesagt, hab ich schon nie gehört.
Und für was steht das?
Dann steht das S wahrscheinlich nicht für Storage, sondern Security
Professional
Certified bla bla bla
Security Professional
Keine Ahnung.
Für was steht das?
Certified Information System Security
Professional, okay.
Hab ich noch nie gehört.
Aber ich beschäftig mich auch null
mit diesem ganzen
Zertifikats-Ökosystem da.
Ich halte das
zum größten Teil für
überflüssig und eine
in sich geschlossene Gelddruckmaschine.
Es hat mich auch keiner danach
gefragt, also ich hab mich ja, also
vor zwei, also
Ende 2022
hab ich mich
ja beworben, auch wenn ich
da natürlich schon ein bisschen Glück hatte mit
Empfehlung, da
hingekommen zu sein, ja.
Musste ich mich ja trotzdem noch
bewerben, aber mich hat
ich, ich mein, ich mein ich hab ganze
zwei Vorstellungsgespräche gemacht, ja.
Ich hab ein Vorstellungsgespräch gemacht
in Würzburg
bei einer Firma, wo mich einer angeschrieben hat,
den ich noch von früher kenne,
der ist da jetzt
Teamleiter und die suchen Leute.
Bei denen war ich und dann war ich
in Frankfurt bei der Versicherung.
Da kannte ich auch jemand, der da arbeitet,
der hat auch gesagt, hier Max, wir suchen Leute, willst nicht zu uns.
Und der hat meine
Skill-Liste und Bewerbung quasi schon
zum Chef durchgeschleust, damals,
bevor ich mich überhaupt online beworben hatte
und ich war grad Weihnachtsbaum
kaufen im Bauhaus, das weiß ich noch.
Da hat mich der Chef damals angerufen
und hat gesagt, ja hier, Herr Max,
wann passt's bei Ihnen, wollen Sie nicht vorbeikommen?
Also, da hatte ich schon
einen Bonus, aber trotzdem, in beiden dieser
Vorstellungsgespräche hat mich nicht einmal
irgendwer nach irgendeinem Zertifikat
gefragt.
Der einzige generell, der da
fiese Sachen gefragt hat, war der Mann von der
Personalabteilung, der wollte wissen, ey,
ihr müsst euch das mal vorstellen,
ich hatte irgendwie
2001 oder so,
hab ich in meinem Lebenslauf
nicht genau beschrieben,
was ich gemacht hab.
Also irgendwie zwischen
Schule aufgehört
und
Ausbildung und Zivildienst gemacht
und dazwischen war irgendwie, fragt mich nicht,
ein Dreivierteljahr nicht aus dem Lebenslauf
ersichtlich.
Und da fragt er mich ernsthaft,
ja, ich hab in den Lebenslauf
geguckt,
was haben Sie denn
Ende 2001 gemacht?
Oder Ende 2002?
Oder, ich weiß nicht mehr, was er für einen Zeitraum
genau gefragt hat, da musste ich auch
sagen, boah,
Mensch, das ist
23 Jahre her, wo soll ich denn
jetzt wissen, was ich da gemacht hab?
Ja, also ich kann euch
sagen, was ich da gemacht habe.
Ups.
Richtig.
Ich kann euch sagen, was ich da gemacht hab.
Ich hatte keinen Bock auf
Arbeiten, Ausbildung oder sonst was
und ich habe 24
7 MMO Kreiselgrind gemacht.
Das hab ich gemacht.
Ich hab 24 7 MMO gespielt und hatte auch
keinen Bock, irgendwas anderes zu machen und hab mir gedacht,
warum kann man nicht einfach
für den Rest seines Lebens
24 7 MMO Kreiselgrind machen?
Ich finde, Leute, eine
sehr berechtigte
Sinnesfrage, oder?
Warum kann man nicht
sein ganzes Leben 24 7 MMO
Kreiselgrind machen? Ich finde,
man sollte jedem, der 24
7 MMO Kreiselgrind machen will,
das ermöglichen.
Nicht jeder hat das Glück wie
Esmongold, 24 7 MMO Kreiselgrind
machen zu können und Millionär zu werden.
Ich hab intensiv deine Teamfähigkeiten
trainiert.
Das ist natürlich eine schöne
Umschreibung des Ganzen,
aber ich hab's schon oft
gesagt, am Anfang,
als das mit Homeoffice bei Corona
angefangen hat, ich konnte euch
sofort sagen, welcher
der Leute MMO-Erfahrung hatte
und welcher nicht. Oder sagen wir mal nicht MMO-Erfahrung,
aber sagen wir mal, wer
Online Gaming Experience hatte und
wer nicht. Die Boomer
Leute, die mit Online Games
null am Hut hatten, haben sich
extrem schwer getan, was Homeoffice und
generell so elektronische
Kommunikation über Teams und
Skype hat, gab's ja damals teilweise noch
und sowas anging,
hatten Mikrofonqualität, so als hätten sie
das. Wisst ihr, kennt ihr die Leute,
die in Teams drangehen?
Mittlerweile ist es
besser geworden, weil die Leute oftmals
von dem Arbeitgeber das Equipment
gestellt bekommen und sowas. Aber damals,
gerade als das angefangen hat
mit Homeoffice während Corona,
da hast du jemand angerufen bei Teams,
der ist dann teilweise nicht rangegangen
und dann ist er drangegangen irgendwie gefühlt nach
zwei Minuten Teams klingeln
ist er drangegangen und das hörte
sich dann an.
Also, das hörte
sich an, als hätte der quasi
ja wahrscheinlich, also das Mikrofon
im Bobbes oder so.
Also, unterste Qualität
Build-In
Notebook
Mikrofon, während
das Notebook auf
keine Ahnung
auf der
Waschmaschine im Schleudergang steht
so nach dem Motto, hat sich das angehört.
Alter, was ist denn mit euch
los, Mann?
Was habt ihr für Mikros
am Start? Und die Leute
konnten sich auch nicht muten und sowas
und du hast bei
Leuten mit MMO und generell
Online-Gaming-Erfahrung gemerkt, erstens
die hatten ihre Kommunikation online
im Griff, die wussten genau, wann man
sich mutet, wann man sich entmutet, manche
haben sogar sich darüber beschwert.
Also, Leute, es war ein
sicheres Zeichen damals, dass jemand
Online-Gaming-Erfahrung hatte,
wenn er gefragt hat, wo kann man
bei Teams Push-to-Talk einstellen?
Weil Push-to-Talk
eigentlich eine sinnvolle Sache ist, aber Push-to-Talk
gibt es ja bei Teams immer noch nicht so richtig.
Es gibt quasi so Mute-Shortcuts,
also richtig echtes
Push-to-Talk gibt es in Teams nicht.
Was ich übrigens immer noch ziemlich bescheuert
finde, ich finde Push-to-Talk
eigentlich die beste Variante immer noch.
Man kann das natürlich selbst machen, Push-to-Talk.
Ja, du kannst
das mit Windows-Shortcuts machen, so nach dem
Motto, nur unmuten, wenn ich einen Knopf drücke
und es geht.
Aber blöd, dass Teams das immer noch nicht
standardmäßig unterstützt, Push-to-Talk.
Push-to-Talk ist
das Beste.
Ja. Und
du hast das gleich gemerkt, ich war mit Leuten
bei mir, damals aus dem Team in Teams,
von denen ich wusste,
der eine hat viel CS gespielt,
der andere war auch ein MMO
Progress Raider mit irgendwie was, was ich
nicht, 300 Leuten oder so zusammen.
Und
da hast du gleich gemerkt, wenn wir zusammen in Teams
gehockt haben, das war
Informationsaustausch-mäßig,
Kommunikationsmäßig
überhaupt kein Problem. Das hat
besser funktioniert als Offline.
Ohne Scheiß, hat besser
funktioniert als Offline.
Und dann kam irgendjemand
rein, wir hatten damals jemand ein bisschen älteres,
der hat sich um unser Mailsystem gekümmert,
scheiß Mikrofon,
kein Plan, wie man online mit den Leuten
redet.
Das sind dann so Leute, die in
Teams-Chat schreiben,
sehr geehrter Herr Max,
das System
ist heute Morgen
langsam. Bitte um schnelle
Analyse. Mit freundlichen Grüßen
ihr Anwender.
Also wenn
einer über Teams so schreibt,
da weißt du schon Bescheid.
Die Leute,
die online ordentlich kommunizieren konnten,
die haben einen Link gepostet,
haben gesagt,
jemand, der wusste, wie man online
kommuniziert, der hat einfach den Link
genommen,
hat gesagt hier und
ist kaputt
oder so.
Das war's.
Leute, die wussten, wie man online kommuniziert,
haben im Prinzip das gepostet. Link und dann
irgendwie ist kaputt, fertig.
Da wusstest du Bescheid.
Vielleicht haben die noch dahinter geschrieben,
irgendwie so was wie
Leute rufen mich schon an,
guck mal.
Aber wenn einer in Teams anfängt,
Romane zu schreiben, dann weißt du schon Bescheid.
Ultra Boomer Alert.
Also man hat,
deswegen bin ich eigentlich drauf
gekommen, man hat mit
MMO-Kreiselgrind und
generell Online-Spielen tatsächlich
seine Teamfähigkeit
trainiert. Das wird
vielleicht von manchen Leuten belächelt,
aber ich finde, das ist wirklich
der Fall. Gerade wer mal
online wirklich competitive was gespielt
hat, das muss jetzt nicht
CS oder irgendwie
Apex, Overwatch,
LOL oder irgendwas
sein, ist vollkommen egal.
Irgendwas, der wird feststellen,
das können auch irgendwelche
PvE-Rates oder so sein, wo es halt
bisschen drum geht, optimiert
zu spielen. Und optimiert
bedeutet in der Regel auch, dass man
sich eben mit seinen Teammates
ordentlich austauschen muss.
Dass man dann nicht sagt,
oh holl der Recke,
dieser
Zauberer steht mit dem Feuer im
... Dass man nicht Roleplayt,
sondern sagt, was weiß ich,
Agro auf Heiler, oder so
was.
Und dann sagt dann der Off-Tank,
so nach dem Motto, ich taunte.
Dass man halt weiß, ey, okay, bam, jeder weiß,
was Sache ist, kurz, zackig,
du weißt Bescheid.
Wenn man
irgendwas, auch nur semi-competitive,
online gespielt hat, der lernt
kurze, knackige
Kommunikation,
auch in hitzigen
Situationen.
Ihr wisst wahrscheinlich,
was ich meine.
Und das hat was gebracht.
Und du hast sofort gesehen, bei den Leuten,
die da ein bisschen
Online-Gaming-Erfahrung hatten, und die nicht.
Die nicht, die haben sich super schwer
getan mit Teams und reiner Online-Kommunikation.
Und für die anderen Leute war das
das Normalste der Welt.
Und für die hat das schon quasi in der ersten Woche besser
funktioniert, als offline im Büro sitzen.
Ja, so sieht's aus.
Ich muss sagen, ich find Teams
gar nicht so schlecht. Also was mich
an Teams abfuckt, ist, dass es manchmal einfach
einen weißen Bildschirm
hat und sowas, wo du denkst, ja, was macht's denn
jetzt? Aber im Großen und Ganzen
ist Teams
immer noch am erträglichsten,
würde ich sagen.
Am liebsten würde ich ja Discord auf der Arbeit verwenden.
Gibt's aber nicht.
Auch Discord, wisst ihr?
So cool Discord ist,
Discord hat einige Basic-Funktionen
nicht, wo ich mich frage,
warum nicht?
Ihr hattet Teamspeak schon. Zum Beispiel,
mal ein Beispiel, was in Discord
nicht geht, ist, alle muten außer
einen in einem Channel.
Warum geht sowas in Discord nicht?
Das ist für irgendwelche größeren
äh, Zerg,
PvE, größere Raids,
was auch immer, ist das eigentlich
das Wichtigste überhaupt.
Dass du, also ich glaube,
es geht, also ich glaube, was man
in Discord machen kann, ist, dass man so einen Moderated
Channel hat, wo Leute zuhören
können, aber nur manche reden. Das geht, glaube ich.
Was aber nicht geht, ist, dass
man, dass man kleinzeitig, dass ich
jetzt sage, ey, ich will niemand
hören in diesem Channel,
außer den, den und den. Teamspeak geht
das. In Discord musst du
immer alle von Hand muten, was halt
richtig für ein Arsch ist, weil
da kommen neue Leute rein und so.
Naja, also eben im Großen und Ganzen
ist Discord schon cool,
gerade weil Discord eben das alles
schön kombiniert.
Von Videocalls
bis Chatgeschichten,
Community Channels,
eigene Server,
wo Leute sich zu einem Thema austauschen können.
Also Discord ist quasi ein Best-Of.
Aber, muss sagen, gerade in Richtung
Audio
Features
für Spiele ist
Discord nicht das Beste, was es gibt.
Sowohl von Latency als auch von Features her.
Also mich wundert's
nicht, dass Leute heute standardmäßig
immer noch Teamspeak verwenden,
die Competitive spielen.
Sei es CS-Leute
oder
Valorant, von Valorant-Leuten weiß ich's.
Ja, du kannst
davon ausgehen, dass Discord das gleiche macht.
Ist das so?
Weiß ich gar nicht.
Okay, dann gucken wir uns mal.
Ja, also Leute, ich kann's nochmal sagen, wo ich's grad nochmal
aufhab. Falls irgendjemand ein Herz
für Sammy hat und Sammy ermöglichen will,
dass er bald wieder laufen kann,
brauchst du die Seite nochmal unten in den Chat
rein. Geht auch über PayPal
für Sammy zu spenden.
Man sieht, was ich ein bisschen
blöde finde, ist, dass die
Tierheimbetreiber meistens ein bisschen oldschool
sind und sich mit Technik nicht so auskennen,
weil die hätten auch ohne Probleme irgendwie so
eine GoFundMe oder sowas machen können.
Dann hätte man gesehen, wie weit das Ganze noch ist.
Also, falls jemand ein Herz
für Sammy hat, jeder Euro hilft
und
mal gucken dann,
falls die auf meine Mail antworten,
wovon ich mal ausgehe, weil die wollen ja Kohle haben.
Ich werde dann den Rest bezahlen für Sammy,
wenn das nicht zusammenkommt.
Gucken, wie viel da noch übrig ist.
Weil die wollen ja, dass Sammy wieder laufen kann.
Ja, so, was gucken wir uns jetzt an?
Verwendet eigentlich...
Nee.
Ich hab noch niemand gesehen, der TS5 verwendet.
Und der Witz ist,
sogar TeamSpeak mimt da drüber
auf Twitter selbst rum.
Das ist ja nur Schrott.
Es ist ja nur Schrott.
MW2 Remastered Multiplayer ist hier.
Den Mod haben die wieder eingestampft mittlerweile, ne?
Activision.
Es gab wohl nen Modern Warfare 2 Remastered Multiplayer Mod
und der wurde jetzt direkt eingestampft,
paar Tage nach Release.
Weil Activision gesagt hat,
Ihr werdet eures Lebens nicht mehr froh,
wenn ihr das nicht mehr einstellt.
Es gibt wieder ein neues Projekt.
Ja, das...
Es dümpelt jetzt ein bisschen vor sich hin,
bis es so groß wird, dass Activision denkt,
wir machen's dicht.
Ey, was will der für nen Scheiß in Polen kriegen, ne?
Was haben wir denn sonst noch hier?
Critical IPv6.
Das Problem hab ich nicht.
Einfach IPv6 ausschalten.
Reicht nicht?
Okay, dann muss ich mir das Video jetzt doch mal angucken.
Übrigens, ich hab ja CrowdStrike Aktien gekauft, ne?
Die sind
von 192 auf 230
wieder gestiegen.
Ich hab's euch gesagt.
Ich hab damals gesagt,
vor ein paar Wochen,
die Leute sind vergesslich
as fuck, was sowas angeht.
Und die haben schon so viel Geld
reingesteckt.
Niemand ändert das jetzt.
Das war so klar.
Ich hab leider nur 2 Stück gekauft.
2 Aktien gereicht, ja?
Ich hab 2 CrowdStrike Aktien.
Ne, heute kann ich nicht.
Heute ist überall zu.
Ich verkauf die am Montag dann wieder.
Es war einfach nur...
Nicht, dass ich irgendwie...
Ich wollte einfach nur
mal wissen, ob mein Gefühl stimmt.
So, das wird keinen interessieren.
Das geht einfach wieder hoch danach.
Und ich hatte Recht.
Keine Sau interessiert.
Also, das war's für heute.
Bis zum nächsten Mal.
Tschüss.
Ich hab die V6 ausgeschaltet.
Also, nur mal von der Theorie her, ja?
Manipulierte IPv6-Pakete.
Das bedeutet ja,
im Endeffekt,
dass wenn ich
eine Webseite anbiete,
die per IPv6
erreichbar ist,
jeder, der diese Webseite besucht,
oder irgendeinen Service
von mir besucht,
wo ich die Kontrolle drüber habe,
wie die Antwortpakete aussehen,
den könnte ich infizieren, ja?
Irgendwie eine Webseite gemacht,
jemand besucht die über IPv6,
Bam!
Also, das ist wirklich heftig.
Theorie, nur Windows,
so wie es aussieht, ja?
Das ist wirklich heftig.
Wenn du dir vorstellst,
du kannst potenziell infiziert werden,
nur durch den Besuch,
oder noch nicht mal einer Webseite,
die über IPv6 geht,
über ihre Webseite,
dann ist das wirklich heftig.
Das ist wirklich heftig,
wenn du dir vorstellst,
du kannst potenziell infiziert werden,
nur durch die Webseite,
die über IPv6 geht,
über irgendeinen Service,
der über IPv6 geht.
Also, wenn ihr IPv6 benutzt,
dann ist die Chance wahrscheinlich
relativ hoch, sich was einzufangen.
Es scheint schon einen Patch zu geben, ja?
So, that's why it's very important...
Da stand eben, dass es immer geht,
was wie wo.
Naja, IPv6...
Disabling IPv6 is ineffective.
Aber ich bekomme gar keinen
IPv6-Traffic,
wenn ich nicht
IPv6 verwende.
Also, das würde dann nur betreffen,
dass mich ein Rechner
lokal infizieren kann.
Weil, wenn ich über IPv4 ins Internet gehe,
bekomme ich nie irgendwelche
manipulierten IPv6-Packages
zu Gesicht.
Ja, wenn ich am PC ausgeschaltet habe,
ist ja das Gleiche, weil dann gehe ich auch nicht über IPv6
im Internet, auch wenn ich könnte.
Also, ich muss schon irgendwann IPv6-Service im Internet
aufrufen und IPv6-Antwortpakete
bekommen, dass das ausnutzbar ist.
Was gehen würde wahrscheinlich, wenn man
IPv6 eingeschaltet hat und
über irgendwelche
Wege fängt man sich
beispielsweise eine andere
Malware ein, auf einem der Rechner
in diesem Netzwerk, dann könnte
von dort alle lokalen
Rechner infiziert werden über diesen
IPv6-Bug. Das würde
funktionieren, ja. Oftmals ist es so, dass man
ja solche Sachen schon
für sich schlimm genug, aber
in Kombination werden die halt manchmal richtig
beschissen, ja. Also so könnte zum Beispiel
wenn ich mir, sagen wir mal,
ich lade mir irgendeine manipulierte
App auf meinem
Android-TV runter,
dann könnte die manipulierte
App von meinem Android-TV
alle meine Windows-Rechner über diese
IPv6-Lücke infizieren, wenn ich lokales
IPv6 in irgendeiner
Art und Weise ansprechbar bin.
Also das ist nicht so komplex
in der Natur.
Oder auch nicht, oder auch wenn ich
nicht ansprechbar bin über IPv6, ja.
Und das halt in Kombination ist heftig.
Es ist sehr wichtig, diese
Sicherheitspatche anzuwenden, auch
in Bezug auf das
CVE-2024-38063,
Ach das!
das ist der Tracker für den
IPv6-Death-Packets-Bug,
da sind 90
andere Tracking-Vulnerabilitäten
die gepatcht wurden,
vor allem drei, die
einen Attacker ermöglichen,
System-Level-Privilegien auf
einer kompromissen Maschine zu erhöhen,
und zwei weitere kritische
Remote-Code-Execution-Bugs,
Ja, ja, geht ja bei Windows wieder richtig zur Sache gerade.
wenn du den Line-Printer-
Daemon-Service nutzt,
oder du nutzt Microsoft
Edge in Printer-Daemon-Service,
Ach, irgendwas
uraltes.
in Internet-Explorer-Mode,
Was?
Wer macht denn sowas?
Das ist eigentlich viel mehr üblicher als du denkst,
besonders in großen Unternehmen.
Ja gut, die haben wahrscheinlich auch noch Silverlight-Apps da, ne?
Brauchst du das?
Viele haben Software, die mit Internet-Explorer
gearbeitet wurde,
und sie wurden nie richtig portiert,
um mit modernen Browsern zu arbeiten,
als sie da waren.
Und sie waren wahrscheinlich nicht portiert,
weil der Originaler, der diese Software geschrieben hat,
und niemand anders versteht,
wie das Programm funktioniert,
und das assuming, dass sogar der Autor
dieses Codes versteht, wie es
in erster Linie funktioniert hat.
Aber dieses alte Mess von Spaghetti-Codes
funktioniert immer noch, und es ist
kritisch für die Funktionalität der Unternehmen,
also musst du es zu etwas bezeichnen,
das zumindest ein bisschen wie Internet-Explorer
erscheint.
Und das ist der Grund, weshalb
der weltkönigste Lieblings-Webbrowser
bis heute noch technisch lebendig ist,
nur als eine seltsame, vestigte
Browser.
Aber Internet-Explorer hat ja mittlerweile
einen guten Nachfolger in Safari.
Mit Safari.
Es ist zwar nicht ganz so schlimm,
wie mit Internet-Explorer damals,
aber Safari gibt sich Mühe,
aufzuholen, was das angeht.
Also so zu werden, wie Internet-Explorer.
Safari hat,
wenn es hier,
wenn man sich hier mal beispielsweise
Features anguckt,
von modernen,
also das erste Mal, Safari hat
prinzipiell immer die schlechtesten Scores.
Und wenn man sich neue Features anguckt,
in der Regel kannst du davon ausgehen,
dass Safari und auch
Safari iOS oftmals
der Browser ist, der irgendwas nur
halbherzig unterstützt.
Also Safari ist, was das angeht, auf dem besten Weg,
der neue Internet-Explorer zu werden.
Überlegt, überlegt euch mal.
Darüber könnte man sich
theoretisch sogar
diese Sache einfangen.
Wenn du eine Windows-Suche machst,
ja wobei, das geht zu Microsoft-Services
dann wahrscheinlich nicht.
Well, I'm pretty sure that most Windows-Machines
have the printing services
enabled by default.
There's still a chance that those daemons
could be disabled.
Because I remember back in the Windows Vista
days, when I was gaming on a low-spec
laptop, that there were these
different optimization guides
available and even automated tools
that did the optimizations for you.
And one option
was for disabling...
Just as a quick aside, let me know...
Wie sind wir denn jetzt
bei Classic RuneScape
gelandet auf einmal?
When you think print spoolers
and other services are
maybe less than
ubiquitous IPv6
has become in recent years.
When I first started
learning networking, it was hardly
used anywhere, but according to
Google statistics, over
40% of people
worldwide are accessing
Google over...
IPv6.
And in the United States
it's just over half.
Guck mal, in Germany gar nicht.
Habt ihr's gesehen?
In the United...
In... in Deutschland
gar nicht.
It's just over half.
Und in Afrika gar nicht, überhaupt nicht.
Das mag aber daran liegen, dass generell aus
Afrika wenig traffic kommt.
... accessing Google over IPv6.
And since Google is the most accessed website
in the world, I think that this is about
the largest sample size that
is gonna be available for...
Ich hab auf Polen gezeigt?
Ach ja, tatsächlich, das ist Frankreich,
das ist Deutschland, ihr habt recht.
Geografie-Cakeweight, Alter.
Stimmt.
Portugal, Spanien,
Frankreich, Deutschland?
Polen?
Da unten ist die Schweiz, oder?
Hier, nee, warte mal, das ist Österreich,
da pflege ich schon ein, das ist Italien, das weiß ich.
Dänemark?
Äh...
Norwegen, Schweden, oder Schweden-Norwegen?
Finnland?
Australien!
Das weiß ich. Australien?
Kanada?
USA?
Ich glaube,
Brasilien?
Argentinien ist auch hier irgendwo.
Wo ist Gibraltar? Kein blassen Schimmer.
Südafrika.
Das kann ich mir noch merken.
Zeig mal auf Indien.
Das hier müsste Indien sein, oder?
Das hier müsste Indien sein, das hier müsste China sein.
Hier ist irgendwo,
ist hier, glaube ich, irgendwo
hier so, ist auch Thailand?
Keine Ahnung, irgendwo da so?
Australien, Neuseeland?
Oder ist das Neuseeland?
Kein Schimmer.
Ähm...
Hier nahe Osten? Irgendwo?
Ach, keine Ahnung.
Geografie-Cakeweight.
...
Okay, Moment.
Das muss ich mir anhören.
Ja, so, easy.
...
Heißt, einfach patchen.
Okay?
Patch Champ machen.
Gucken wir hier.
Okay, anscheinend habe ich es schon gepatcht, hä?
Sonst würde es ja hier irgendwo drinnen stehen.
Oder welcher Patch ist es denn überhaupt?
Ne.
Dann habe ich schon gepatcht.
Patch Champ.
K, B, 1, 5, 8, 5?
Ne.
Ich habe schon gepatcht.
Patch Champ ist schon durch.
Das hat er bestimmt gestern schon gemacht.
Ist es nicht?
K, B, weiß nicht.
Da stand eben was anderes, oder?
K, B, 5, 0, 4.
Was?
1, 5, 8, 5.
Ach, ist es das?
Ah, okay.
Ja, dann muss ich das noch machen.
Chatge.
Ich kann jetzt aber nicht neu starten.
Dann ist das Stream aus.
Mache ich nach dem Stream.
Ich gehe eh nicht über IPv6 ins Internet.
Also insofern.
Müsste ich erst mal safe sein.
Es sei denn, ihr seid schon drinnen, Leute.
Seid ihr schon drinnen?
Ne, kein Reboot jetzt.
Was haben wir denn sonst noch hier?
What if we teleported oceans to Mars?
Der sagt, dass ich das Video schon geguckt habe.
Das lief wahrscheinlich im Hintergrund.
Die dunkle Seite von HDMI.
Das ist doch bait, oder?
Weil was soll an HDMI so schlimm sein?
HDMI ist ein bisschen...
Okay, ich sage euch mal was aus meiner Sicht.
Das ist ziemlich...
Es sagt an HDMI, dass der letzte HDMI-Standard, der verbreitet ist von, fragt mich nicht, 2011 oder so ist.
Und dass die nicht mit aktuellen Entwicklungen Schritt halten können, was DisplayPort angeht.
Also du kannst DisplayPort 4K 240 Hertz, geht.
HDMI geht nicht.
Deswegen benutzt im Prinzip jeder aus seinem Computer heutzutage einfach DisplayPort.
Gut ist.
Die Content-Industrie ist natürlich sehr scharf darauf, auf HDMI.
Wegen Kopierschutz, HDCP.
Wobei, ehrlich gesagt, da bin ich mir jetzt nicht ganz sicher.
Aber ich glaube, HDCP geht auch ohne Probleme über DisplayPort.
Also der Kopierschutz ist der gleiche.
Ist also egal, über was das geht.
Die Zukunft werden eh USB-C-Kabel sein, predikte ich mal.
Also nicht unbedingt...
Und die, wie soll man sagen, die unmittelbare Zukunft.
Es wird schon noch eine Weile DisplayPort, HDMI und so, wird uns schon erhalten bleiben.
Ich glaube, die Zukunft sind USB-C-Kabel.
Wobei man sagen muss, dass im Prinzip die USB-C-Kabel auch nur DisplayPort über USB-Kabel machen.
Also das ist nach wie vor DisplayPort, obwohl es ein USB-C-Kabel ist.
Meines Wissens nach.
Also es ist im Prinzip einfach nur über ein anderes Kabel.
Müssen die Hardware herstellen?
Das kommt auch dazu.
HDMI kostet Lizenzgebühren.
Ja.
Okay, gucken wir mal.
Mal gucken, ob das was taugt.
Keine Ahnung, ob das Video was taugt.
Aber es geht bloß 9 Minuten 45.
War DisplayPort nicht eher da als HDMI?
Das weiß ich gar nicht.
Aber es hat sich eine Zeit lang hauptsächlich HDMI durchgesetzt.
In der...
Gerade was so Fernsehgeräte und sowas anging.
Also...
Ich kann mich dran erinnern.
Also so die Progression von Displayanschlüssen.
Das erste was man hatte waren VGA-Kabel.
Solche Dinger.
So die guten alten.
Wie hießen diese Dinger?
VGA-Kabel war ja eigentlich nur die Noob-Bezeichnung.
Irgendwas mit R.
Was sagt da Wikipedia zu?
Wikipedia.
Okay, nee.
Dann ist die wirklich tatsächlich VGA.
Ich bilde mir ein, die hießen irgendwie streng genommen anders.
Irgendwas mit R.
Das war ein D-Sub-Stecker, genau.
So, danach...
Oder sagen wir mal so, am Ende gab es DVI.
Und DVI gab es ja auch in unterschiedlichen Ausführungen.
Ja, mit rückwärtskompatibel zu VGA, ohne rückwärtskompatibel zu VGA.
Also sprich, die hatten dann hier einmal das, dann hier so ein Kreuz.
Da gab es unterschiedlichste DVI-Sachen.
DVI hatte aber irgendwann Probleme.
Es gab doch auch noch Dual-DVI oder irgendwie sowas.
Gab es doch auch noch.
Oder wie hieß das?
Dual-Link?
Ja, genau.
Das war irgendwie so ein super dickes Kabel.
Und genau, das hat man gebraucht für damals höhere Auflösungen und Bildwiederholrate.
Aber das war trotzdem zu wenig.
Das war trotzdem zu wenig.
Das war zu wenig Bandbreite.
Danach gab es irgendwann HDMI.
Ja, und dann kam Displayport und halt Displayport über USB-C auf.
Zwischenzeitlich...
Gut, ganz früher gab es für Fernseher noch SCART.
Falls das jetzt noch irgendjemand kennt.
Hat noch irgendjemand Horrorvorstellungen bei diesen komischen Anschlüssen?
SCART.
Und dann gab es noch S-Video.
S-Video.
Das gab es.
Das gab es auch noch.
So, und dann gab es mal ganz kurzzeitig, als HD neu war.
Also, als es schon HD-Fernseher gab, aber noch kein HDMI.
Dann gab es...
Ja, diese Composite-Anschlüsse gab es noch.
Aber das meine ich nicht.
Äh, doch, das meine ich.
Genau.
Dann gab es noch diese Stecker hier.
Das waren so die ersten 720p-Dinger.
Kamen auch Capture-Cards damit.
Da gab es noch diese ganz normalen, diese RCA-Kabel-Dinger.
Ja, und dann gab es im Prinzip Displayport.
Da gab es noch Mini-HDMI.
Gibt es auch.
Wo man sich fragt, warum ist das so ein Ding?
Und dann Displayport.
Also, meine Prediction ist, es geht eindeutig Richtung USB-C.
Auch bei Grafikanschlüssen.
Displayport-Anschlüssen.
Kitsch-Kabel-Kerl.
Das waren ja gerade die, die wir gerade gesehen haben, Freunde.
Und...
Aber es wird noch eine Weile Displayport-Output und so weitergeben.
Noch HDMI.
Aber ich...
Meiner Meinung nach ist HDMI...
Die Zukunft...
Äh, nicht HDMI.
USB-C.
Die Zukunft für Displayanschlüsse.
Obwohl das halt, wie gesagt, auch nur Displayport über USB ist.
So, gucken wir mal, was der hier zu sagen hat.
Wenn das Video sackt, machen wir aus.
Was?
Und nein.
Sicherheit.
Moin, Michael, 50 Billionen.
...unser Leben deutlich verbessert und hochauflösende Bild- und Audioübertragung etabliert.
Was würden wir nur ohne HDMI machen?
Was anderes benutzen wir?
...beantwortet uns gerade das Leben, denn HDMI stirbt gerade aus.
Was soll uns dieser...
Diese Frage...
Also, irgendeiner muss ja ein Stock-Video gedreht haben, wo man sowas sieht.
Warum kommst du auf die Idee, ein Stock-Video zu drehen, wo du einen HDMI-Stecker ins Wasser steckst und dann wird das Wasser rot?
...beantwortet uns gerade das Leben, denn HDMI stirbt gerade aus.
Ach, du meinst, er macht Wasser zu Wein.
Also quasi, so wie der HDMI-Jesus sozusagen.
Aber, warum?
Dann leuchtet's ein.
Seit 2002 hat sich HDMI kontinuierlich weiterentwickelt und sämtliche Konkurrenz vom Markt gefegt.
Es gab lange einfach keine anderen Anträge und sämtliche Konkurrenz vom Markt gefegt.
Es gab lange einfach keine anderen Anschlüsse.
HDMI war ein Monopol.
Es hat nicht mehr gewirkt wie eine Idee, die auch anders gelöst...
Bei HDMI-Steckern ist immer das Problem...
Also, hatte ich heute Morgen wieder?
Ja?
...dass die keine Widerhaken haben oder keine Schrauben.
Wenn man die so einfach rein- und rausziehen kann.
Heute Morgen ist er an meinem zweiten PC.
Der HDMI-Stecker rausgerutscht und ich hab mich gefragt, was los?
Ist er jetzt kaputt?
Ja, USB hat seine Tücken, da geb ich dir recht.
USB 6.9, Gen 18.1, 5x3.
Und was auch immer.
...gewürgt wie der Anschluss.
Und niemand hat's hinterfragt.
Und irgendwie ist's auch immer noch so in unserem Kopf.
Wenn wir einen Bildschirm anschließen wollen, brauchen wir ein HDMI-Kabel.
Ich glaube, ich hab außer meinem Fernsehen die letzten Jahre nix mehr über HDMI angeschlossen.
Doch in der aktuellen Version HDMI 2.1 gibt es ein riesiges Problem.
Ja, der Standard ist von 2011 oder sowas.
Und die Bandbreite ist einfach viel zu gering.
Das ist das Ding.
Die schaffen es überhaupt nicht, Schritt zu halten mit DisplayPort.
Viele Geräte, auf denen HDMI 2.1 vermerkt ist, bieten überhaupt nicht alle versprochenen Features an.
Das ist ja bei USB auch so.
Doch wie kann das sein?
Bei Lebensmitteln ist genau geregelt, dass das, was drin ist, auch auf der Packung stehen muss.
Sollte...
Das ist ja eines der bescheuertsten Vergleiche ever.
Wenn ich in ein Glas reingucke und sehe, aha, da sind Oliven drin.
Okay, da sind Oliven, ja.
...eigentlich selbstverständlich sein.
...und nicht...
...und zwar bei allen Produkten.
Wieso ist das bei der Technik jetzt anders?
Dazu muss...
Also bei USB ist es ganz offensichtlich, weil der USB-Standard mittlerweile 350 verschiedene Sachen hat,
die alle kacke benannt sind.
Und teilweise man den neuen USB-Standard draufschreiben darf, obwohl man eigentlich nur den alten unterstützt.
Und das Schlimmste bei USB ist, ich weiß, es geht um HDMI, aber ich sag das mal für USB.
Das Schlimmste an USB ist, dass die Retroaktivität,
die Sachen umbenennen.
Also du hast dir mal was gekauft, das war USB 3.1, auf einmal heißt das offiziell USB 3.2,
obwohl es genau das gleiche ist.
Und das heißt auf einmal USB 4 und es ist das gleiche wie USB...
Leute, also...
...habe ich ja schon ein paar Videos drüber gemacht.
Das ist kompletter Wahnsinn, was die bei USB da treiben.
Ich habe fast den Eindruck manchmal, dass die Leute, die im C++-Gremium sitzen,
und in diesem USB-C...
...Gremium-Konsortium,
dass es da große Überschneidungen gibt bei den Leuten.
Weil beide machen kacke.
Man versteht, wieso HDMI überhaupt erst so erfolgreich werden konnte.
Das Industriekonsortium, also ein Zusammenschluss mehrerer Firmen, die HDMI entwickelt und eingeführt und standardisiert haben,
hat eine große Gemeinsamkeit.
Panasonic, Philips, Sony, Thompson & Thompson...
Sony?
Ich wusste das, Sony ist klar.
Sony war der einzige, wo ich mir sicher bin, der ist dabei.
Stimmt.
Sie stellen nämlich allesamt auch Fernseher her.
Und entgegen unserer Erwartungen ist HDMI nicht einfach ein Ergebnis einer kleinen Forschungsgruppe,
die ihre Idee gratis der ganzen Welt zur Verfügung gestellt hat,
sondern eben ein Verkaufsprodukt von Tech-Riesen.
Kein Wunder also, dass es heutzutage im Grunde keinen halbwegs aktuellen TV zu kaufen gibt,
der nicht mindestens einen, meistens eher drei oder vier HDMI-Anschlüsse hat.
Aber nicht, dass...
Ja, Intel, Intel ist ja das beste Beispiel dafür, ne?
Warum USB, warum die Probleme?
Intel hat mit USB 3.2 damals gesagt, sie hören auf mit Thunderbolt,
äh, Thunderbolt ist das Intel-USB,
und übergeben dieses gesamte Ding jetzt in die Hände des USB-Konsortiums.
So.
Daraufhin hat sich das USB-Konsortium so dämlich angestellt mit USB 3.2,
dass Intel wieder gesagt hat, das können wir keinem zumuten,
und hat Thunderbolt 4.0 bzw. ihr eigenes USB wieder gebastelt.
Was jetzt wieder mit USB 4.0 quasi in dem Konsortium übergeben werden sollte.
Nee, äh, Lightning, Lightning ist Apple.
Aber Apple hat ja auch mittlerweile USB-C.
... für den Kunden etwas Schlechtes ist. Ganz im Gegenteil.
Die Unternehmen haben den Kunden eine moderne Alternative...
Nee, Thunderbolt ist Intel. Guck.
Ja, die Dinger gab's damals noch, ja.
Die PS3...
... musste man damals...
... über diese Kabel an eine Capture-Card anschließen,
weil die PS3 über HDMI ausschließlich HDCP-geschützte Sachen übertragen hat.
Du konntest damals nicht capturen über HDMI die PS3.
Ich glaube, das geht heute immer noch nicht.
Deswegen musstest du das damals über dieses hässliche Ding anschließen an die Capture-Card.
... einzelner Kabel alle notwendigen Signale und Informationen
über einen einzigen Anschluss gebündelt am Ziel ankommen.
Weniger Kabelsalat, mehr Komfort und sogar mehr Qualität...
Das ist das...
... das Zielankommen.
Weniger Kabelsalat...
Das... exakt dieses Bild hatte ich auch schon in einem Thumbnail mal drin.
... mehr Komfort und sogar mehr Qualität.
Mit Sony, Philips und Thomson waren zusätzlich auch noch drei der Entwicklerfirmen an der Entwicklung der Blu-Ray-Technologie beteiligt.
Ah, ja.
Wer kennt noch Blu-Ray? Das sind doch diese DVDs, die Leute nur noch günstig über Willhaben verkaufen, oder?
Oder gibt's die noch in Geschäften?
Anyways, auch diesem Prozess konnten sie den HDMI-Stempel aufdrücken.
Wer zur damaligen Zeit Filme in HD schauen wollte, kam gar nicht um HDMI herum.
Den ersten Konkurrenten, das seit 1999 entwickelte Digital Visual Interface, hatte die neue Schnittstelle schnell an der Tasche.
Zusätzlich zum...
Ja, kann man Konkurrent sagen? Das war halt schon vorher da und war eigentlich schon damals ziemlich Pains-Champ-DVI.
Ich hab übrigens jahrelang...
immer noch ein VGA-Kabel im Rucksack mitgetragen, weil...
Mittlerweile nicht mehr, aber damals, weil so gut wie alle Beamer...
VGA-Anschlüsse hatten.
Ja genau, Beamer, richtig.
Zum VDI-Kabel, das nur Bildsignale überträgt, brauchte man auch noch eines für den Ton.
Das fiel durch HDMI weg und die Auflösung mit HDMI war auch noch besser.
Ja.
Ab hier war DVI also...
tot.
Und das ist zur Abwechslung keine überspitzte oder übertriebene Aussage.
DVI findet man zwar durchaus heute noch, warum genau ist aber niemandem ganz klar und meistens fehlt der Anschluss sowieso komplett.
Vier Jahre später wurde HDMI vom Monopol-Podest gestoßen.
Der Konkurrent...
Bäm.
DisplayPort.
Vor allem Gamer bekommen das sofort mit, jede Grafikkarte hat plötzlich DisplayPort.
Ja.
Oder Mini-DisplayPort.
Niemand wirklich wusste, wieso das plötzlich da war.
Doch.
Ich kann euch das gleich sagen, warum das da war.
Einmal Lizenzkosten und weil der HDMI, der letzte HDMI-Standard von, frag mich nicht, 2011 ist und die Bandbreite nicht ausreicht für hohe Auflösung und vor allem hohe Bildwiederholrate.
Besser ist in irgendeiner Form.
Ist er.
Ohne wild drum herum zu reden.
Was ist denn heutzutage besser? HDMI oder DisplayPort?
Das bedeutet DisplayPort 2.0 gegen HDMI.
Okay, Leute, ich hab Mist erzählt.
Der Standard ist nicht von 2000, äh, Dings, der ist von 2017.
Okay.
DVI hat doch die VGA-Pins eingebaut.
Nicht jeder DVI-Stecker ist rückwärtskompatibel zu analogen Sachen.
Da gab's auch drei, vier verschiedene Ausführungen von DVI.
Aber guck mal, hier sieht man ja schon das eigentliche Problem.
Es geht, also wenn...
Ja, okay, sagen wir mal so.
Der neueste Standard würde gerade so ausreichen.
Aber guck mal hier.
Nen, nen, nen, 240 Hertz mit ordentlicher Auflösung.
Das ist jetzt, das geht halt nicht.
Und DisplayPort hat damit halt überhaupt keine Schmerzen.
DisplayPort macht sogar zweimal 4K mit 144 Hertz.
Ja, und die Bandbreite sieht man auch.
Bandbreite ist einfach deutlich größer.
Maximal Anzahl Audiokanäle.
Ja, gut, das stört jetzt nicht wirklich.
Ja.
HDMI 2.1.
Datenübertragungsrate bei HDMI 48 Gigabyte pro Sekunde.
Moment, war das jetzt nur ein Versprecher?
Jetzt muss ich, jetzt muss ich mal ganz überkorrekt sein.
Datenübertragungsrate bei HDMI 48 Gigabyte pro Sekunde.
Sagt der Gigabit oder Gigabyte?
DisplayPort 80 Gigabyte pro Sekunde.
Der sagt Gigabyte.
Sekunde.
Ha!
Exposed, nicht richtig gelesen.
Dem reichen die 48 in aller Regel mehr als aus,
soweit jetzt nicht irgendeine ganz neue Technologie ins Spiel kommt,
die da irgendwie mehr Daten überträgt.
Nur ein Problemchen, denn diese 48 Gigabyte kann man nicht wirklich ernst nehmen.
Wenn ihr ein Kabel oder ein Gerät kauft, auf dem HDMI 2.1 steht, bedeutet das...
Einheit fail, Einheit fail.
...dass auch HDMI 2.1 drinsteckt.
Ja.
Wie kann denn das jetzt sein?
Um so etwas zu verhindern, gibt es ja eigentlich exakt spezifizierte Standards.
Und es ist genau festgelegt, was HDMI 2.1 kann.
Das Problem an der ganzen Nummer, das Logo für HDMI 2.1 verpflichtet den Hersteller völlig idiotischerweise nicht.
Wie bei USB.
Dazu auch alle Features von 2.1 zu implementieren.
Wie gesagt, nur weil USB 4 draufsteht, ist das noch lange kein USB 4 Kabel.
Die aktuelle Konsolengeneration wirbt beispielsweise mit dem HDMI 2.1 Logo.
Also unter anderem auch einer Bandbreite von 48 Gigabyte pro Sekunde.
Die Xbox schafft allerdings maximal 40 Gigabyte pro Sekunde.
Bei der PS5 sind es sogar nur 30.
Der Unterschied ist deutlich.
Bei Konsolen jedoch nicht so dramatisch wie bei Kabel.
Moment.
Der Unterschied ist der, dass du Probleme hast, die native Auflösung deines Displaygerätes zu erreichen.
Das ist vielleicht ein bisschen verkompliziert jetzt, wie das dargestellt wird.
Ja, also keine Ahnung.
Du hast einen 4K 120 Hertz Fernseher und du wunderst dich, warum du nicht 4K 120 Hertz auswählen kannst.
Schafft die Konsole eh nicht, aber es macht oftmals Sinn, zumindest die native Auflösung auszuwählen.
Kauft ihr euch nämlich für eure...
Darkstar, dankeschön für den Sub.
Ist das eine KI-Stimme?
Nee, ich glaube nicht.
Der spricht einfach nicht, sondern ist engaged.
... Xbox ein HDMI-Kabel auf dem HDMI-Kabel.
Auf dem HDMI 2.1 draufsteht, kann es sein, dass es trotzdem nur 18 GB pro Sekunde übertragen kann.
Ja, das Problem ist, die meisten Leute haben doch keine Ahnung von der Bandbreite.
Das geht im Prinzip darum, dass du nicht die richtige Auflösung auswählen kannst.
So nutzt euch eure teure Hardware am Ende gar nichts, weil das Kabel diese Geschwindigkeit gar nicht leisten kann.
Eine absolute Katastrophe.
Das verwirrt die Leute doch jetzt nur.
... für alle, die sich dessen nicht bewusst sind.
Am Ende vermuten die Verbraucher die Schuld für eine schlechtere Performance vielleicht sogar noch bei der Konsole, obwohl die gar nicht das Problem ist.
Für nicht so technisch affine Menschen ist das das reinste Chaos.
Eine Lösung gibt es nämlich nicht.
Man muss bei jedem einzelnen Produkt...
Nee, ich glaube nicht, dass das eine KI-Stimme ist.
... Dinge.
Lass mal kurz gucken.
Oldest Video.
Vor drei Jahren.
Gab's das schon? Gab's das schon?
Egal, was ihr gerade spielt, ihr seid sicher super überzeugt, dass euer...
Das ist der gleiche Typ.
... das Beste ist.
Meine Oma hat immer gesagt...
Früher war alles...
Das ist der gleiche Typ mit anderen Mikrofonen.
... ab.
Mit anderen Mikrofonen, anderen Settings.
... ob Konsole, Kabel oder PC, jedes Feature einzeln suchen und kontrollieren ist dennoch deutlich mühseliger und einfach nervig...
Ja, das ist bei USB auch so.
... erst den besten Kabel zu greifen, auf dem HDMI...
Und da ist es auch kacke.
... 2.1 steht und zu hoffen, dass es alle gewünschten Features hat.
Am Ende kleiden ausschließlich die Käufer darunter...
Alternativ kann man sich einfach nicht das billigste HDMI-Kabel kaufen und dann ist man in der Regel schon auf der sicheren Seite.
Hersteller können so minderwertige Produkte mit einem kleinen Logo deutlich aufwerten und attraktiver machen.
Zumindest für die, die keine Ahnung haben.
Also wie gesagt, aus meiner Sicht ist das größte Problem, dass HDMI einfach nicht genug Bandbreite hat für aktuelle Monitore.
Das ist vielleicht bei einem Fernseher weniger das Problem.
Du brauchst kein, keine Ahnung, jetzt übertrieben gesagt, 8K mit 144 Hertz oder 4K mit 240 Hertz gibt es kaum im Fernseher.
Aber bei einem Monitor und gerade nachdem immer breitere und immer hochauflösendere Monitore mit auch höherer Bildwiederholfrequenz für Gamer an den Start kommen, ist HDMI schon problematisch mittlerweile.
Dann kommt auch noch die Bildwiederholungsrate mit HDMI-Seite nämlich stuck bei 60 bis 144 FPS. Displayport...
Nein, nicht wirklich FPS.
Also ich will jetzt nicht kleinlicher sein als kleinlich, aber...
... aber...
... es stimmt halt in dem Fall einfach nicht.
... schafft es auch euren 240-Hertz-Monitor voll auszureizen und sogar noch mehr.
Das ist auf jeden Fall ein für uns relevanter und teilweise auch bekannter Unterschied.
Und es gibt noch unzählige andere Vorteile von Displayport.
Das einzige, was HDMI wirklich besser macht, ist die Farbtiefe.
Aber das...
...
Nee.
Sieht man das nicht sogar hier unten in der Tabelle, dass das nicht so ist?
Okay, bei allen...
Hm.
Aber selbst die Ältesten sind standard...
Hä?
Dann ist entweder der Wikipedia-Eintrag, den er gescreenshottet hat, verkehrt oder die
Tabelle verkehrt.
... 60 bis 144 FPS.
Das einzige, was HDMI wirklich besser macht, ist die Farbtiefe.
Aber das hat trotzdem eigentlich alles nichts damit zu tun, wieso HDMI gegen Displayport
verliert.
Ja, das sind rein aus Verbrauchersicht relevante Punkte.
Ich auch nicht.
Aber was, wenn wir euch jetzt sagen, dass HDMI einen riesen Nachteil wiegt?
FürHe.stelle hat?
Ja, Lizenzgebühren.
Normalerweise müsste uns das ja nicht wirklich interessier-
Farbtiefe ist doch ein Bandbreitending auch.
Aber es ist halt die Frage, was da im Standard spezifiziert ist, wieviel geht.
Bandbreite spielt da auf jeden Fall mit rein.
Aber selbst 30 ist eigentlich vollkommen okay.
Du hast dann vielleicht Probleme bei so Sachen wie HDR und so was, würd ich jetzt mal vermuten.
Kenn ich mich nicht so richtig aus.
Aber für normalen Content reichen auch 30 Bit Farbtiefe komplett aus.
In diesem Fall ist es tatsächlich sehr relevant zu verstehen, warum auch die gesamte Linux-Community weg von HDMI möchte.
Haltet euch an, das wird jetzt ein wenig wild. DisplayPort ist ein Lizenzfreier.
Ja, unter Linux ist mal wieder eher die Frage wahrscheinlich, es funktioniert nicht richtig.
Wer ist dran schuld? Die Mesa-Treiber-Leute? Die Grafikkartentreiber-Hersteller?
Ist es der Kernel selbst? Ist es der Desktop? Ist es Wayland? Ist es X?
Ist es irgendeine Vulkan-Implementierung oder doch OpenGL? Oder was ist es?
... Verbindungsstandard. So wie in Autos einfach 3-Punkt-Gurte eingebaut werden können von jedem Autohersteller,
können auch DisplayPorts in jede Hardware bedenkenlos eingebaut werden.
HDMI hingegen ist lizenzpflichtig. Und zwar für jeden Anschluss, der verbaut wird.
Jährlich. Der Hersteller zahlt tatsächlich eine Jahresgebühr für jeden verbauten HDMI-Anschluss an das vorhin schon erwähnte.
Das ist ja das gleiche Problem bei Videocodecs gewesen.
Ich bin mir da aus dem Kopf nicht ganz sicher.
Aber ich glaube, der Videocodec, der standardmäßig bei klassischem SD-Fernseh verwendet wird,
also irgendwie MPEG-2 oder so ist das, glaube ich,
der ist...
... mit Lizenzkosten verbunden.
Deswegen gibt es viele Geräte, die das selbst bis heute nicht gescheit abspielen können.
Und bei...
... H.264 ist es, glaube ich, ähnlich. Also H.264 ist so das, was man standardmäßig heutzutage für nahezu alles verwendet,
wenn man nicht schon was Neueres benutzt.
Jede Grafikkarte hat einen H.264-Decoder drinnen für Videos.
Also die meisten Videos sind heutzutage H.264.
Nicht MP4, wie das manche sagen. MP4 ist nur der Container.
H.264 ist der Kodec, der Videocodec.
Also H.264 kann auch in einem MKV... in einer MKV-Datei oder in einer TS-Datei drin stecken.
Ist egal. Das eine ist der Container und das andere ist der Videocodec.
Oh, ein bisschen zu klug scheißen, ja.
HDMI-Konsortium. Das führt zu Folgeproblemen.
Ein Beispiel ist das Nutzen von Linux mit AMD-Hardware und Grafiktreibern von Mesa.
Hier funktioniert nämlich 4K mit 120 Hz einfach nicht über HDMI.
Bei DisplayPort ist das kein Problem. Das ist Open Source.
Was? DisplayPort ist Open Source?
DisplayPort ist ein Stecker.
Das selbe Problem für HDMI zu lösen ist aber ziemlich kompliziert.
Nachdem das Ganze nämlich nicht Open Source ist, musste AMD bei HDMI anfragen wegen dieses Problems.
HDMI hat der...
Ja, oder ein Pro... Ach, die meinen... Okay, jetzt verstehe ich, was er meint.
Dass man... dass quasi das Protokoll und die Funktionsweise offen ist für jeden, um das quasi zu implementieren, um zu bauen.
Und bei HDMI ist das nicht der Fall.
Support dafür, aber ganz einfach abgelehnt und das Problem damit unlösbar gemacht.
Was erstmal klingt wie ein absolutes Nischenproblem,
müsst ihr euch nochmal auf der Seite der HMD-Konferenz ansehen.
... der Zunge zergehen lassen.
Denn ein Anschluss, der so ziemlich überall verbaut ist, kann scheinbar entscheiden, wo weiterhin Softwarelösungen erscheinen und wo nicht.
Ohne dass sie eine Möglichkeit für Entwickler bzw. Hersteller anbieten, diese Dinge selbst zu lösen.
Bei DisplayPort hingegen kann die Softwarelösung einfach jeder selber basteln.
Das HDMI-Format gesagt, HDMI 2.1 darf nicht überhaupt ein Source-Treiber sein.
Ja, das ist scheiße.
Guck mal, das ist übrigens auch ein Unterschied hier.
Diese Widerhaken.
Es gibt übrigens auch DisplayPort.
Ohne Widerhaken, ja.
Aber ich finde diese Widerhaken eigentlich ganz praktisch.
Zumindest, sagen wir so, zumindest auf Monitor-Seite, da wo das Ganze hochkant ist.
Manch einer sagt, er finde das nicht gut, weil wenn er am Kabel hängen bleibt, rutscht halt das Kabel raus und er reißt sich nicht die Grafikkarte weg.
Okay.
Kann ich auch nachvollziehen.
Das ist in Wirklichkeit Freiheit und Demokratie gegen tyrannische Diktatur.
Ja, jetzt ist aber mal...
Das war ein bisschen übertrieben.
In der Gaming-Welt übernimmt DisplayPort ohnehin gerade langsam als der neue Standard.
Wie lange die TV-Industrie braucht, um hier nachzuziehen, ist unklar, aber unserer Meinung nach nur eine Frage der Zeit.
Dabei ist es nicht mal wichtig, unbedingt DisplayPort zu verwenden, sondern Hauptsache nicht...
Wie gesagt, ich glaube, HDCP geht auch über DisplayPort.
... bei dem, je.
Die neueste Lösung, die scheinbar auch technisch alles bisherige in den Schatten stellt, ist etwas, was wir auch alle kennen.
USB-C.
Aber es ist DisplayPort über USB-C.
Muss man sagen, bin ich mir zu 90% sicher.
Vielleicht sind ja zukünftig alle Geräte ausschließlich über USB-C verbunden.
Technisch ist es möglich.
Und besser als HDMI ist es allemal.
Funktionieren da Netflix-DRMs zum Beispiel DisplayPort?
Ähm, ja.
Nachdem die auch HDCP machen, können, würde ich sagen, ja.
Was denkt ihr? Ist das HDMI-System fair?
Aber ich wusste ja bei diesen ganzen Audio-Videos...
... Sachen sagen, so hundertprozentig kenne ich mich da nicht aus.
Also es kann auch sein, dass ich Mist erzähle.
Kann es so überhaupt weiter existieren mit derartiger Konkurrenz?
Sagt's uns in den Kommentaren.
Okay, bye!
Monke ist...
Oh, guck mal, wir haben noch ein FireShip-Video. Das kenne ich noch gar nicht.
Browser Wars.
Ah, ich weiß, um was es geht. Vermute ich mal.
Ich vermute, es geht um Manifest V3 und Deaktivieren von...
... Sachen.
Ich fand das Video auch nicht so gut.
Gibt es eigentlich DisplayPort zu USB-C-Adapter?
Jaja, mit Sicherheit gibt es das.
Du brauchst aber auf der Rechnerseite halt, was das Video über USB-C unterstützt.
Und...
Also...
... So.
eine aktuelle, moderne Grafikkarte,
die USB-C hat?
Wie funktioniert
denn das eigentlich bei USB-C?
Also ich kenne das von meinem
Arbeitslaptop.
Der schließt man nur noch bei USB-C an
und da kann man auch
USB-C auf Displayport machen.
Mal angenommen,
ich stöpsel jetzt einen Monitor
mit USB-C
an meinen
normalen USB-C Stecker
am Rechner.
Ist das dann irgendwie ein Pass-Thru
von der Grafikkarte
über meinen normalen
USB-C Stecker am Gehäuse?
Geht das irgendwie intern?
Oder muss
der USB-C Stecker an der
Grafikkarte sein, dass man
es anschließen kann?
Beim PC schließt du Displayport von
der Grafikkarte ans Mail-Mail und kannst sagen,
aha, okay,
das ist mein Rechner,
mein Rechner ist von 2022,
der ist ja nicht modern genug.
Da habe ich sowas, glaube ich, noch nicht.
Also ich kann mich nicht daran erinnern, dass ich da irgendwas
eingestöpselt habe. Oder?
Das müssen wir jetzt mal gucken.
Gigabyte
Z
Elite
Ref 1.x oder so.
So, das hier müsste mein Mainboard sein
und da ist nichts zu sehen
von irgendwelchen Displayport
und HDMI-Steckern.
Also ich habe eine
eine
RTX 4090.
Guck mal, ich habe doch hier Geizhals.
Ich habe doch irgendwo hier meinen Rechner
Geizhals-Linked.
Also ich habe das da
und ich habe die Grafikkarte.
Ist da in irgendeiner Art und Weise
meine Grafikkarte? Ist da in irgendeiner Art und Weise
irgendwas für...
Es hat einen extra Stand, dass es nicht
zu sehr wackelt, beziehungsweise nicht so
sehr am Slot zieht.
Da sehe ich nichts.
Und auf meinem Mainboard,
wir suchen uns jetzt mal kurz das...
uns mal kurz das Handbuch raus.
Seht ihr da irgendwas?
Ich sehe da nichts für...
Nice.
2018. Aha, die hat ein USB-C.
Okay, meine hat kein USB-C.
Weil die Games da
komische Links generiert.
Also meine Grafikkarte hat kein USB-C-Output.
Sieht man ja auch hier.
Ist auch sonst nichts dabei.
Außer ein RGB-Gedöns.
Und mein Mainboard hat
auch keinen Anschluss irgendwie.
Der USB braucht
USB-C-Alt-Mode-Support
beziehungsweise USB-Tunneling.
Aha.
Siehste?
Das ist... Habe ich mich nie mit beschäftigt.
Durchaus möglich, dass er das kann.
Aber ich habe hier eh gar kein USB-C-Monitor,
um das auszuprobieren. Ich habe mich einfach nur mal interessiert.
HDMI-Forum verhindert...
Kein HDMI 2.1
unter Linux wegen HDMI-Forum.
AMD kann kein
HDMI 2.1 für die Radio-Anbauten.
Schuld ist offenbar das HDMI-Forum.
Also ist das
mit irgendwelchen
restriktiven Hersteller
Konsortium-Dingern.
Ja, mein Notebook hat einen USB-C-Ausgang.
Mein Arbeitsnotebook.
Das hat USB-C.
Das kannst du über die Dockingstation machen.
Und
ich habe da aber auch einen Adapter dabei.
USB-C auf Displayport.
Das HDMI-Forum hat unsere Vorschläge
leider abgelehnt. Na dann.
Haben sie besser verdient.
Das ist halt weiter ein Trend von
dir gehört die Hardware,
aber du kannst trotzdem nichts damit machen.
Du hast zwar gekauft,
aber bist trotzdem gearscht.
Übrigens,
wollte ich euch gerade noch mal was zeigen.
Wo wir gerade dabei sind.
Guck mal da. Neuer
Wagen-Rekord.
87,15 Kilo.
Ich habe damit quasi jetzt
21,5 Kilo abgenommen die letzten
Jahre über.
Und wenn ich da vor Kacken gegangen wäre,
wäre es wahrscheinlich 187.
Übrigens eine Sache, die mich super
verwirrt hat, ist...
Ah, Twitter funktioniert ja wieder nicht mehr richtig,
wenn man eingeloggt ist.
Es hat einer eine Antwort auf diesen Post
gepostet.
Da habe ich wieder an der Menschheit
gezweifelt, Leute.
Guck mal, eine Antwort...
Eine Antwort auf meinen
Post hier.
The fuck? Was ist mit ihm los?
Also das ist eine Antwort auf...
Twitter ist so beschissen geworden, Mann.
Du kannst doch nicht mal hier Tweets und die
Antworten, die da drunter angucken
mittlerweile. Zumindest auf meinen
Post schreibt dieser Typ hier...
Wen juckt's?
Bin ich froh, dass meine Stadt...
Hä?
Meine Stadt?
Ist das ein Bot? Ist das
AI-generated?
Wen juckt's? Bin ich froh, dass
meine Stadt und meine Mädchen... Und jetzt
kommt ja der Hit bei denen.
21 Jahre, 23 Jahre, 17 Jahre, 31 Jahre,
4 mal 20 Jahre
nicht oberflächliche Idioten ohne
Erziehung sind, die einen nach dem
Äußeren buddeln, nicht alle körperlich
werden gesund. What? Also, was mich
daran verwirrt ist,
der hat 8 Kinder
und 6 Kinder
davon sind
quasi fast
gleich alt.
Der hat quasi 6 Kinder,
die zwischen 20 und 23
sind.
Oder was meint der? Oder was meint der?
Was meint der mit meinen Mädchen?
Das ist bestimmt...
Also, ich bin mir ziemlich sicher, dass
das entweder ein Bot ist
oder so ein
Ragebait
Ragebait Posting
Typ. Also, ich glaube nicht,
dass da einer
dahinter sitzt, der das so ernst meint.
Aber auszuschließen ist auf Twitter
nix. Ich bin nicht
Body Positivity genug.
Genau.
Profil öffnen. Nee, nicht
on stream.
Das traue ich mich nicht, jetzt aufzumachen,
das Profil.
Ja.
Aber ich bin nicht Body Positivity
genug, anscheinend für ihn.
Save den Bot.
Es ist... Ich glaube, dass es so...
Also, wenn es ein Bot ist, dann ist es so ein
Ragebait Bot.
Das ist ja generell angesagt
in letzter Zeit. Also...
Es ist ja erwiesen,
dass wenn du absichtlich Fehler in deine
Videos einbaust, dass du
mehr Engagement
bekommst, weil die Leute
dich darauf hinweisen wollen, dass du falsch liegst.
Ich meine, eines der größten Reflexe,
die die Menschheit so hat, ist
Achtung, im Internet hat einer was Falsches
gesagt, ich muss den jetzt
korrigieren.
Du glaubst, der ist echt, okay.
Nun ja, kann ja sein.
Es gibt auch blöde Leute,
die echt blöd sind
und
die
nicht nur dumme Bots sind.
Sogar sagen, der Großteil der Leute, die sind echt dumm.
Und nicht nur dumm, weil sie Bots sind.
Das FireShip Video
mega Upload for... Ja, das Kim.com Video
haben wir uns am Anfang angeguckt.
Murksa, dankeschön für den Sub.
Exzellente Subscription, nice.
Ein richtig echter
Self, danke für den Sub.
Jetzt geht's aber los hier.
Sogar Besos
unterwegs zu uns hier, persönlich.
Fox Subscriptions, Leute.
Ist dein Onkel, ja, ja.
Genau, mein Vater arbeitet auch bei Microsoft
und bannt dich jetzt auf Xbox Live.
Menschahn.
Pock, dankeschön, ja, Leute, für die ganzen
Subs. Huge.
Falsches Emote.
Ey, jetzt geht's aber los hier.
Jetzt wird's aber übertrieben.
Daily Steel, Pock.
Nice Subs.
Ich muss,
ich muss mehr streamen, das stimmt.
Und ich muss im Stream mehr Sellout machen
für Subs, weil jedes Mal, wenn ich dazu was sage,
kommen die Leute um die Ecke.
Ach ja, man könnte mal wieder subscriben.
Aber ich mach das ja nicht, weil ich irgendwelche
Subs haben will.
Warum streame ich eigentlich?
Hauptsächlich, weil ich das selbst...
Entspannend ist das
falsche Wort.
Ich finde es zu einem gewissen Grad
entspannend zu streamen und vor mich hin
zu schwätzen, ja. Und zu gucken, was ihr
drauf sagt.
Wann machst du die Stellenanzeige fertig?
Du meinst quasi die restliche Browserleiste,
die restliche Tab-Leiste hier oben?
Vielleicht...
Ich weiß nicht, ob ich's sagen soll.
Ich wollte sagen, vielleicht einfach
heute Abend, aber ihr erkennt mich, ich sag öfters,
ich streame einfach Sonntagabend nochmal und
komm da nicht mehr.
Also, ja.
Ich muss auf jeden Fall, und das ist jetzt wirklich
echt mal Zeit,
ich muss ein neues YouTube-Video machen.
Das sind drei Themen, die ich am Anfang gesagt hab.
Ich hab nämlich damals,
als ich das,
wo ich einen neuen Job gesucht hab, noch ein paar Videos zugemacht hab,
ich hab den Leuten versprochen, ich zeige euch mal meine Bewerbung,
mit der es geklappt hat,
und ich muss mein jährliches Gehaltsupdate-Video
machen und wie es im neuen Job so läuft.
Weil ich vermute, dass das gerade die Leute,
die sich die Videos angeguckt haben, quasi
dann vor einem Jahr, dass das irgendwie
auch auf ein gewisses Interesse stößt.
Weil ich das damals halt ja relativ
öffentlich gemacht hab mit
ich bin unglücklich auf der Arbeit, ich suche einen neuen Job,
ich hab was Neues gefunden, ich hab mich beworben,
es lief gut, jetzt hab ich neu angefangen.
Dann hab ich einfach nichts mehr gesagt.
Ich kann's aber hier nochmal sagen, ich bin immer noch happy,
da wo ich jetzt bin. Mittlerweile bin ich angekommen
und das merk ich daran, dass mir Sachen
schon wieder auf den Sack gehen.
Das ist eine Sache, die ich festgestellt hab,
sobald euch wieder anfängt,
Sachen auf den Sack zu gehen, dann seid ihr da
vollkommen angekommen. Weil nirgendswo ist perfekt,
und gerade wenn ihr neu seid
und super motiviert und so,
dann guckt man sich so die negativen
Sachen und die Sachen, die nervig sind, da guckt man so
drüber weg und sagt, oh ja, ist ja nicht so wild,
kam mir noch einmal vor. Aber wenn man dann mal ein Jahr
da ist und sich eingelebt hat,
eingelebt hat ist glaube ich das richtige Wort,
dann hat man Sachen, die einem
auf den Sack gehen und man weiß auch, okay,
es ist nicht alles perfekt und es gibt
genug Sachen, die mir auf den Sack gehen, aber
es ist nicht mal
im Ansatz
in diesem Umfang und
in diesen Punkten, die mir beim alten
Arbeitgeber auf den Sack gegangen sind.
Jetzt sind das eher so, da sind's
eigentlich eher so Kleinigkeiten so, ja.
So nach dem Motto von
manchmal Besserwisser im Team,
die mich nerven, vorbei.
Ich glaube, ich nerv auch manchmal,
Leute. Ja, oder
was gibt's denn da sonst noch?
Ja, irgendwelche Budget-Sachen.
So nach dem Motto, wir wollen aber
einen Kubernetes-Cluster, aber wir wollen
nicht mehr als einen Node bezahlen. Das ist kein Witz,
Leute, muss ich euch erzählen.
Es gibt bei uns so
die Anforderung, ja,
diese Software, die soll auf dem Kubernetes-Cluster laufen,
aber wir haben nicht
genug Budget. Kannst du mal gucken,
dass dieser Node, dass dieser Kubernetes-Cluster
nur mit einem Node läuft.
Da hab ich dann auch drauf gesagt,
Leute, das macht keinen Sinn.
Auf der einen Seite wollt ihr einen Kubernetes-Cluster
haben und die Vorteile davon,
aber dann nur einen Node.
Wenn ihr nur einen Node habt
und nur einen Node bezahlen wollt, dann
stellt eine VM hin, das muss kein Kubernetes-Cluster
sein. Stellt eine VM hin,
installiert den Kram drauf und gut ist.
Nee, aber in unserem Handbuch, es gibt
so, weiß nicht, ob das Handbuch ist, es gibt so
so ein, ja,
so ein Projekthandbuch, keine Ahnung, wie das
genau heißt, da steht halt drinnen, dass
die Architektur auf Kubernetes aufgebaut sein soll.
Und das ist halt so ein Ding,
das ärgert mich dann immer, wie kann man
auf die Idee kommen, ein Kubernetes-Cluster
hinzubauen und quasi
die Vorteile haben zu
wollen,
von Skalierbarkeit, von Rolling
Updates und solchen Geschichten,
aber dann nur sagen, ja,
budgetmäßig aber bitte nur einen Node.
Mit einem Single
Node Kubernetes-Cluster hast du legit
so gut wie nichts gewonnen,
ein paar Sachen schon, ja, dass du beispielsweise
die Config abstrahieren kannst über YAML-Files
und was auch immer, oder du hast dann mit
einem Single Node Kubernetes-Cluster so gut wie
nichts gewonnen und hast dir sehr viel
Komplexität mit ins Boot geholt
versus eine VM.
Das macht aus meiner Sicht überhaupt
keinen Sinn, einen Single
Node Kubernetes-Cluster, nein, es
geht nicht darum, Kubernetes-Cluster
Erfahrungen zu sammeln, das könnte
man anders machen. Da läuft
wirklich aktiv produktive
Live-Software drauf.
Du kannst den später noch
skalieren, ja.
Aber du hast
jetzt keinen Vorteil davon. Und
wie hoch ist die Chance, dass wenn ein
Projekt gestartet wird mit, wir wollen aber nur
einen Single Node, dass das später nochmal hochskaliert wird.
Das wird später höchstens hochskaliert,
wenn dann nochmal neue Software dazu kommt.
Ja, also du musst quasi
ein Kubernetes-Cluster betreiben,
der kein richtiger Cluster ist.
Ja, ja klar.
Wenn die Leute sagen,
also ich meine, ich könnte
sicherlich einfach zwei Nodes laufen
lassen. Da müsste ich aber die ganze
Zeit drüber diskutieren, da habe ich keinen Bock drauf.
Wenn die Leute sagen, sie wollen
ein Single Node Kubernetes-Cluster, dann sage ich
denen, dass ich das bescheuert finde, ein Single Node Kubernetes-Cluster
zu betreiben. Und wenn die das
weiterhin haben wollen und
die Nachteile
in Kauf nehmen,
die man ihnen dann ja auch bei Gelegenheit immer
wieder mal aufs Brot schminken kann,
was juckt's mich? Bitte
nachschauen.
Also,
mittlerweile, nee, nee, Google Cloud
sind wir zum größten Teil.
Es ist ein Managed GKE Cluster,
aber mit nur einem Node.
Also ich meine, du hast immerhin die Control Plane
hochverfügbar von Google betrieben,
ja, so ist es nicht.
Aber trotzdem, so Sachen wie Rolling Updates
und sowas, kannst du halt komplett knicken
gescheit mit einem Single Node Cluster.
Was eines der coolen Sachen ist,
es gibt bei
es gibt auch dort Möglichkeiten,
containerisierte Workloads außerhalb
von einem Kubernetes Cluster laufen zu lassen.
Das wäre wahrscheinlich sogar die bessere Variante
in dem Fall, aber nein. Sie wollen ja
explizit einen Kubernetes Cluster haben,
aber nur einen Node.
Ich mach
mir da mittlerweile gar keine großartigen Gedanken
mehr darüber, wenn solche merkwürdigen
Sachen kommen. Ich sag das dann,
dass ich das für bescheuert halte
und dass es die und die Nachteile hat und
wenn sie es trotzdem haben wollen, kriegen sie es.
Ich spreche wie, dass ich 70% der Woche
nur am Mieten bin.
Ich spreche das regelmäßig bei meinem Chef
in unseren Rückspracheterminen an,
aber ich bin da
komplett schmerzlos mittlerweile.
Ich denke mir, wenn die Firma,
wenn das Unternehmen das will
und wenn die mich bezahlen,
für 70% rumsitzen und schwätzen,
dann nehme ich auch
die Kohle und sitz 70% rum
und schwätz.
Es ist ja nicht so, als hätte ich mir das ausgesucht.
Das wollen die ja explizit so haben.
Und wenn die das explizit so haben wollen,
soll mir es recht sein.
Wirklich 70% oder
nur gefühlt, ich würde sagen
gefühlt 70% und in Wirklichkeit
auch 70%. Ich habe euch ja schon öfters
mal meine Kalender
hier vorgelesen
und machen wir mal
ein Beispiel wieder.
Du bist auf der Arbeit quasi auch am streamen
mit drei Viewern.
So habe ich das noch nicht gesehen.
Ja, das ist kacke.
Ich habe letztens was gesehen,
das wollte ich mal ausprobieren.
Das ist irgendein
irgendein
Analysetool gewesen,
das kann dir die Limits
ausrechnen für deine Workloads,
indem du sie eine Weile quasi unlimitiert laufen lässt.
Das zeichnet das quasi
auf und sagt dann
die Anwendung
braucht so und so viel, in Spitzen so und so
viel und
ja, wir würden empfehlen
dort keine Ahnung 4 CPUs
und so und so viel RAM.
Das haben sie in irgendeinem Video gesehen.
Das klang eigentlich ganz cool, gerade für solche Fälle.
Ich kann dir aber nicht mehr sagen, wie das hieß.
Habe ich in irgendeinem Youtube Video gesehen.
Eigentlich eine coole Sache.
Ja.
Wenn man nicht weiß, was
die Anwendung haben will.
Auf der anderen Seite
die meisten Anwendungen, wenn sie zu wenig RAM haben
crashen
beziehungsweise haben Probleme.
Bei zu wenig CPUs sind sie halt lahm.
Schwer zu sagen.
Ja.
Aber da kann man doch
also ich würde es wahrscheinlich so probieren.
Ich weiß nicht, wie praktikabel das bei euch ist.
Ich würde halt irgendein Limit setzen, von dem ich denke,
dass es passt.
Und man kann
ja mit ordentlicher Metrikauswertung gucken,
ob der Kram jetzt
permanent irgendwie
am Anschlag läuft oder nicht.
Und wenn das Ding permanent am Anschlag
läuft und es Performanceprobleme gibt,
kann man es ein bisschen erhöhen. Aber wobei,
so macht ihr es wahrscheinlich, gell?
Wenn ich das richtig interpretiere.
Deswegen musst du laufen die YAMLs
anpassen, weil die feststellen, dass
die Limits nicht ausreichen.
Und die nicht in der Lage sind, euch ein ordentliches Limit
zu sagen. Also sprich, ihr müsst
jede Woche quasi immer stückweise das Limit
erhöhen, bis es dann irgendwann passt.
Wenn ich das mal so rein
interpretiere. So, also passt mal auf. Dienstag,
Leute. Dienstag.
20. August.
Montags arbeite ich nicht.
Deswegen überspringen wir das mal. Dienstag.
Projekt-Produkteam-Sprint-Review.
Geht los.
9.30 Uhr.
So.
9.30 Uhr für eineinhalb Stunden.
Danach kommt Team-Daily.
Beziehungsweise nicht danach. Während ich
das eine habe, kommt das Team-Daily.
Um 10.
Das heißt, da kann ich nicht teilnehmen, weil Paralleltermin.
Dann geht's
weiter um 11.
Projekt-Sprint-Retrospektive.
Eineinhalb Stunden.
Dann geht's weiter.
14 Uhr.
Danach kann ich was essen. Okay.
Ja, das war's. Danach kann ich was futtern gehen.
Dann geht's weiter. 14.30 Uhr.
Projekt-
Backlog-
Refinement.
Danach geht's weiter. 14.30 Uhr.
Ihr stellt fest,
es sind zwei Termine um 14.30 Uhr.
Äh, anderes
Projekt. Sprint-
Planning. Sprint-Planning.
Zwei Stunden. 14.30 Uhr
bis 16.30 Uhr. Da haue ich
aber meistens spätestens 15.30 Uhr
ab. So.
Dann gibt es 15.40 Uhr noch
einen Paralleltermin. Neues
aus der IT. Okay. So, das ist
mein Dienstag. Also, ich kann am Dienstag
realistisch betrachtet, dank
Homeoffice. Sagen wir mal, ich fange
7.30 Uhr an am Dienstag.
Kann ich an diesem Tag
tatsächlich, tatsächlich
ungefähr, sagen wir mal,
eineinhalb Stunden was machen.
Nämlich morgens.
Ja. Das ist tatsächlich nur alle zwei Wochen.
Richtig. Aber das ist nicht so,
dass sonst weniger gemietet wird.
Wie lange gehen die Sprints? Zwei Wochen.
So. Machen wir mal weiter.
Mittwoch.
Mittwoch geht es los um 9.00 Uhr.
Mit, äh, nochmal
irgendwie eine halbe Stunde Berichte,
Berichte Neues aus der IT.
Dann Daily Scrum.
9.30 Uhr.
Dann Service
Jour Fix.
10.45 Uhr.
10.05 Uhr.
Das kann ich euch nicht vorlesen.
Weil dann wüsste man, bei welchem Laden ich bin.
10.05 Uhr.
Ähm.
Wie kann man das jetzt?
Was kann ich denn davon vorlesen?
Was machen die da?
Irgendwas mit Risikomanagement.
Keine Ahnung. Da gehe ich nicht hin.
Aber zumindest ist das, ist das.
Ja. So.
Dann geht es weiter. Mittwoch.
Ähm.
Meeting mit
einem Softwarehersteller.
10.30 Uhr. Meeting mit einem Softwarehersteller,
der für uns Sachen programmiert.
Dann 10.35 Uhr.
Wohlgemerkt, 10.30 Uhr fängt das eine an,
geht 30 Minuten. 10.35 Uhr fängt
das andere an, geht 55 Minuten.
10.35 Uhr. Gruppenmeeting.
So. Danach
kann ich Mittagessen gehen.
Dann geht es weiter. 14.00 Uhr.
Teammeeting. Und dann geht es
15.00 Uhr nochmal
Austausch. Jour fix. Projekt.
Also.
Kann ich vielleicht eine Stunde oder so am Mittwoch was machen,
wenn es hochkommt. Nö. Eigentlich kann ich
am Mittwoch gar nichts machen.
Vielleicht eine Stunde. Ja. Okay. Donnerstag.
Ähm.
9.00 Uhr
Irgendwas, wo ich keine Ahnung habe, was es ist.
Da gehe ich wahrscheinlich nicht hin.
9.30 Uhr Daily Scrum.
10.00 Uhr Teamdaily.
11.00 Uhr ein Blockertermin, den ich mir eingestellt
habe von 11.00 bis 12.00 Uhr, dass ich mal was schaffen kann
die Woche. Blockchain.
14.00 Uhr 15.00 Uhr. Blockchain
Austauschtermin.
Eine Stunde. Okay.
Ich kann tatsächlich, Leute. Premiere am Donnerstag
kann ich zwei Stunden was machen.
Am Freitag auch. Ja.
Also 70% Gemiete kommt doch glaube ich
ganz gut hin, oder?
Und 70%
wieso zwei Dailies?
Ja. Weil mindestens mal mein Teamdaily
und mindestens mal das Projektdaily
am Start sind. Mindestens.
Wenn nicht ab und zu
noch ein paar andere Service Meetings.
So was.
Also ich habe mindestens zwei Dailies täglich.
Nein, nein, nein. Team ist ungleich Projekt. Richtig.
Das ist ungleich Projekt.
Korrekt.
Zwei unterschiedliche Sachen.
Ja. Und deswegen
wird halt 70%
gemietet.
Alter, warum klitscht das ASCII-Aquarium
so rum?
Muss ein Pearl-Problem sein.
Max, gibt's heute Reis mit Lachs?
Korrekt.
Das stimmt aber nicht ganz.
Es gibt
Nudeln mit Lachs.
Weil es eigentlich immer Nudeln mit Lachs gibt.
Und nicht Reis.
Reis mit Lachs gibt's auch manchmal, aber es ist in der Regel
immer Nudeln mit Lachs.
Ja, wie gesagt, mich nervt das auch. Ich spreche das
jede Rücksprachetermin mit meinem Chef
an, aber ich bin halt mittlerweile auf
dem Stand, und das bin ich schon seit ein paar Jahren,
auch beim alten Arbeitgeber schon,
wenn das Unternehmen das möchte,
dass ich 70% in Meetings sitze
und labere und mich dafür bezahlen,
dann ist das in Ordnung.
Ich bin da nicht wählerisch.
Guckt mal, Leute.
Wenn ihr die Auswahl habt, 70%
arbeiten oder 70% rumsitzen
und schwätzen.
Die meisten Leute würden sagen, okay,
rumsitzen und schwätzen wäre mir lieber. Ich muss sagen,
rumsitzen und schwätzen mache ich auch ganz gerne,
aber so ein bisschen höherer Anteil
sinnvolle Technik-Sachen machen
wäre mir lieber.
Ist aber nicht so.
Ich bin da mittlerweile komplett schmerzfrei.
Ich bin ja da auch bestechlich.
Wenn die sagen, Max,
wir bezahlen dir so und so viel
im Jahr, wenn du 70% schwätzt
und rumsitzt und mietest, dann sage ich so,
okay, alles in Ordnung.
Mache ich.
Dann sahnige Soße.
Soße ist tatsächlich gar keine
dabei.
Ich esse ein bisschen Kräuterquark dabei.
Es ist im Prinzip
sahnige Soße. Vergiss, was ich gesagt habe.
Kräuterquark geht als sahnige Soße dabei.
Wann gab es das letzte Mal Burger?
Boah, das ist lange her.
So lange her,
dass ich es dir nicht mehr sagen kann.
Doch, das letzte Mal Burger ist
schon ein paar Jahre her.
Das war aber nicht in Frankfurt, sondern
da habe ich mir bei einem Lieferservice hier
irgendwann mal Chicken Burger bestellt.
Das ist aber auch schon eine Weile her.
Aber jetzt nicht denken,
nur weil ich mittlerweile relativ sportlich
geworden bin, so das letzte
eineinhalb Jahr über,
nicht denken,
dass ich jetzt irgendwie gesund essen würde oder so.
Also ich meine nur,
nur weil ich
21,5 Kilo abgenommen habe
die letzten Jahre über,
heißt nicht, dass meine Ernährung gesünder großartig wäre
als vorher.
War das damals, als du die Lebensmittelvergiftung hattest?
Ne.
Die Lebensmittelvergiftung hatte ich von einem Rahmenschnitzel,
relativ sicher.
Ich hatte damals,
das ist aber schon richtig lange her.
Das ist bestimmt
sechs oder sieben Jahre oder so mittlerweile her.
Ich hatte damals
wie heißen die?
Campylobacter
oder so?
Campylobacter?
Ja.
Da hatte ich richtig heftigen
Dünnschiss davon.
Hat sich dann aber wieder selbst erledigt.
Nach zwei,
drei Wochen.
Und das habe ich mir ziemlich sicher
von einem Rahmenschnitzel
angefangen, wo wahrscheinlich die Rahmensauce
nicht warm genug gemacht
wurde oder verunreinigt war.
Ja Leute, ich kann euch sagen, das war nicht
so spaßig.
Ich habe das auch nur durch Zufall
mitbekommen.
Mir ging es wirklich
nicht gut in diesen
zwei Wochen.
Mit Dünnschiss willst du nicht zum Arzt
gehen. Also habe ich im Prinzip
nur daheim rumgelegen.
Und
ich habe dann mal beim Arzt angerufen, weil ich
gesagt habe, ey Leute, ich liege hier rum,
ich habe Dünnschiss, ich kann nichts machen, ich brauche aber eine Krankmeldung.
Und
da haben die gesagt,
kein Ding, Herr Max,
Krankmeldung, können Sie sich abholen?
Ich habe gesagt, ja, Moment,
mit abholen ist schwierig.
Also damals gab es das noch auf Papier und so
und du musstest das noch per Brief an den Arbeitgeber
schicken und sowas.
So, da habe ich zu meiner Mutter, habe ich meine Mutter
gefragt, ob sie nicht
die Krankmeldung abholen kann.
Meine Mutter ist Krankenschwester, müsst ihr wissen, also war
Krankenschwester, bevor sie in
Rente gegangen ist. Und da hat
meine Mutter zu mir gesagt, weißt du was,
ich bringe dem Arzt jetzt einfach
mal eine
Probe mit von dir.
Also habe ich ins Röhrchen gekackt,
beziehungsweise ein bisschen
ins Röhrchen gepackt und
die hat das dann dort vorbeigebracht
und hat ihnen gesagt, sie sollen das mal ins Labor
schicken. Also meine
Mutter musste quasi dem Arzt sagen, was er zu
machen hat. Und dann haben die das ins Labor
geschickt und dann kam raus,
oh, sie
haben ja Campylobacter und wisst ihr, wie ich das
rausgekriegt habe? Ich habe das
rausbekommen, weil ich
Post bekommen habe
vom, frage ich nicht, Gesundheitsamt
oder sowas? Hast du selber
nachgeschaut, was nachgeschaut?
Ich habe Post vom Gesundheitsamt bekommen,
weil das eine meldepflichtige Krankheit ist.
Sonst hätte ich das nie, hätte
ich das nie mitbekommen. Und
die Krankheit ist allerdings nur meldepflichtig,
so richtig, wenn du in der Gastronomie
arbeitest. Das heißt, ich musste denen
dann sagen,
ich habe nicht,
ich arbeite nicht in der Gastronomie.
Und dann war die Sache gut
und der Doktor hat gesagt, ich soll
einfach zwei Wochen im Bett liegen bleiben und dann geht
das von alleine wieder weg.
Und er hat Recht gehabt, es ging von alleine wieder
weg. Aber das war wirklich scheiße.
Das war im wahrsten Sinne des Wortes
war das scheiße. Hast du den Laden gemeldet,
wo du gegessen hast? Das ist auch so ein Ding.
Ich habe telefoniert,
mit einem von, ich glaube das Gesundheitsamt,
wer auch immer dafür zuständig ist,
mit einem vom Amt habe ich telefoniert.
Und ich habe dem gesagt,
ich glaube, ich habe mir das
eingefangen bei einem
Lieferservice. Das wollte der gar
nicht so genau wissen. Der war überhaupt
nicht interessiert daran, den Namen
und die Herkunft
meiner Sache
zu erfahren. Ich vermute, das
liegt daran, weil er dann hätte was machen müssen,
wenn er das gehört hätte.
Ich glaube auch, die wollten keine Arbeit.
Ich glaube, das ist es gewesen.
Das dachte ich mir dann auch. Der Typ, der wollte einfach
keine Arbeit haben.
Und ich habe nachgeguckt, es gibt
von der Seite an sich,
Verbraucherfenster Hessen oder sowas.
Genau, da gibt es so eine
Die Seite
sieht ja immer anders aus.
Es gibt so eine Übersichtsseite.
Da kann man sich Restaurants
angucken, Hygienemengel
Plattform, ja.
Umkreissuche.
Frankfurt
Hanau
Gucken wir mal.
Irgendwo hier ist doch Hanau, oder?
Ich finde es gerade nicht. Wo ist Hanau? Offenbach?
Hanau?
Hier müsste
Ja, Hanau. Okay.
Was haben wir denn
hier? Kenne ich nicht.
Die Balkanbäckerei. Kenne ich
auch nicht. Da fahre ich öfters
mit dem Fahrrad dran vorbei. Keckweh.
Ja, mein Lieferservice, wo
ich bestellt habe.
Der war hier
irgendwo in Großauheim.
Ja, und da hat man, den habe ich dann auch direkt
gefunden auf dieser, wilder Igel, danke
für den Zap. Den habe ich auch direkt gefunden
hier auf der Seite, diesen Lieferservice.
Der hatte ohne Scheiß drei Seiten
voll mit Beschwerden.
Ja, gucken wir uns mal beispielsweise
an, wie das hier aussieht. Oder gucken wir
mal was in der Balkanbäckerei
ist. Genau.
So sah das auch aus. Die hatten irgendwie
vier Seiten oder so in diesem Restaurant, wo ich bestellt habe.
Hatten schon Beschwerden hier drinnen.
Was ist eigentlich hier?
Hier fahre ich öfters mit dem Fahrrad vorbei.
Verstoß festgestellt.
Ordnungsgemäß
gereinigt. Keine gute
Lebensmittelhygiene.
Reinigung ist
uns... Ja, also ich kann euch das nicht
mal zeigen, weil es auf dieser Seite
leider keine History gibt.
Diese Einträge verschwinden nach,
weiß ich nicht, einem halben Jahr oder so, wenn die
Fehler behoben sind.
Was ich sehr schade finde,
es wäre cool, wenn es eine
Public Wall of Shame gäbe.
Dass man nachgucken könnte, ey,
war bei, keine Ahnung,
diesem Restaurant jemals was?
What the fuck, wie bin ich jetzt da hingekommen?
Und dann kannst du nachgucken. Das wäre nice,
aber das gibt's nicht mehr.
Sollen wir mal Frankfurt der Innenstadt gucken?
Okay, komm, wir gucken mal Frankfurt der Innenstadt.
Gucken wir mal, ob irgendwas... Alter, am Hauptbahnhof?
What the fuck?
Okay, gucken wir mal, ob irgendwas dabei ist, wo ich öfters was
essen gehe. Die Schauspiel jetzt, wundert
mich nicht. Bahnhofsviertel.
Also, was haben wir hier oben?
Indigo, kenn ich nicht.
Kenn ich nicht.
New Asialand kenn ich nicht.
Äh, kenn
ich nicht.
Prince of India kenn
Seven Days Lebensmittel kenn ich nicht. So, hier wird's jetzt schon
interessanter. Kaiserstraße.
Da war ich, glaube ich,
noch nie.
Da war ich auch nicht. Was haben wir hier?
War ich auch noch nicht? War ich
auch noch nicht? War ich
noch nicht? War ich nicht? Okay.
Also, ich hatte bisher in Frankfurt anscheinend immer Glück.
Da war ich schon!
Moment! Moment! Da war ich schon mal!
Was ist das andere?
Paktop? Pakt? Wie jetzt?
Ah, ist das gleiche.
Da war ich schon mal!
Leute, dieses Restaurant,
das wurde schon mal wegen Gammelfleisch
damals geschlossen. Glaube ich.
Glaube ich. Und jetzt, ein paar
Jahre später wieder.
Die hatten mal vor ein paar Jahren,
als dieser Gammelfleisch-Skandal war,
bilde ich mir ein, haben die
dichtgemacht, auch schon.
Okay, also, bei denen
war ich schon mal.
Es wurden nicht unerhebliche Hygienemängel
festgestellt, je nach einer
Beeinflussung...
Scham- und Mäusebefall festgestellt.
Die Betriebsräume waren so
stark verunreinigt, dass eine Grundreinigung
und Desinfektion aller Geräte und Oberflächen
erforderlich war. Der Betrieb wurde...
Moment, die sind schon wieder dicht!
Die waren dicht!
Vor ein paar Jahren schon mal!
Und, okay, also...
Jeder, der da hingeht...
Alter, das hört ja gar nicht mehr auf!
Das hört ja gar nicht mehr auf,
Mann! Okay, man...
Park Choi, Frankfurt. Was haben die für Bewertungen?
So?
Die Bewertungen sind...
nicht so geil...
Achso, das ist Dark Dark Grau.
Ich wollt mal bei Google gucken.
Geht so.
Ja, da war ich schon.
Super.
Es wurde ein Aufkommen an Fluginsekten
festgestellt.
Die Regale waren teilweise mit Mäusekot
verunreinigt.
Die Geschirrspülmaschine
war innen verunreinigt, rochstark
artfremd.
Das ist ja schön umschrieben von
Roch nach, keine Ahnung, Kotze oder so.
Greta Rostock.
Artfremd.
Das ist ja eine schöne Umschreibung.
Das heißt, es roch in der Spülmaschine
nicht so, wie es normalerweise in einer Spülmaschine riecht.
Keine Händereinigung durchgeführt.
Leicht verderblich.
Ach, du Scheiße.
Also, die sind...
im Arsch.
Was haben wir hier unten noch?
Also, es ist nichts dabei,
wo ich schon mal
gewesen bin, so wie es aussieht.
True tasty.
Ja, eher nicht.
Willi Brandplatz haben wir noch.
Hier war mal der Subway früher.
Okay, ne, hier war ich
überall noch nicht, die da drinnen stehen.
Aber, Leute, ich kann euch diese Seite
echt empfehlen, wenn ihr mal nachgucken wollt.
Verbraucherfenster Hessen.
Da
findet man teilweise ganz interessante
Sachen über Restaurants, in denen man schon
gewesen ist. Lass mich mal kurz in Hanau
checken, ob da irgendwas dabei ist.
War ich noch nie...
Oh, da war ich schon!
Rooster, Fried Chicken und Burgers.
Das ist übrigens
der Laden, by the way, wo mich jemand
gefragt hat, wo hast du zuletzt
Burger bestellt? Ich glaube, dort.
Ich glaube, da habe ich die Chicken
Burger bestellt.
Wie gesagt, schon Jahre her, ist wirklich lange her,
wo ich zum letzten Mal Chicken Burger bestellt habe.
Ich glaube, dort habe ich die bestellt,
das letzte Mal.
Okay, ordnungsgemäß
gereinigt. Eine
graue Kiste in dem Mehl
zur Endzubereitung...
Was?
Ach so, war stellenweise mit braunen
Lebensmittelresten verunreinigt.
Okay.
Im Betrieb wurde gegen Befall mit
Schädlingen, Schadnagern
und Ratten vorgenommen. Der
Reinigungszustand...
Sehr schlechte... mehrere Spuren
von Schadnager-Code.
Ich finde, das ist ja nice. Die haben
hier so eine richtig nice
Fachsprache.
Sowas wie, wenn ich
Toslink-Kabel oder so sagen würde.
Schadnager-Code.
Schadnagerfallen.
Ekelhaft abstoßender
Schadnagergeruch wurde
im gesamten Kellerbereich festgestellt.
Okay, die haben da hingepisst und hingeschissen.
Alter...
Ja, gut,
dass es schon eine Weile her ist, wo ich
da zuletzt Burger bestellt habe.
Und ich hoffe mal, dass es zu dem
Zeitpunkt, wo ich da zuletzt Burger bestellt habe,
noch nicht so gewesen ist.
Wenn doch, kann ich es jetzt auch nicht mehr ändern.
Ich habe es aber anscheinend gut verkraftet.
Ja, also Leute, ich poste euch das nochmal rein.
Das ist echt
eine gute Seite zum Nachgucken, wie es mit Restaurants
in der Nähe aussieht. Falls man mal
irgendwohin will oder falls man mal irgendwie
essen war und danach
muss man kotzen oder hatte Dünnschiss oder
Bauchschmerzen, dann kann man mal nachgucken, ob man der Einzige ist,
der da sowas bisher hatte.
Oh Mann.
Ja.
Wer weiß, vielleicht waren da Mäuse
sogar. Mäuse mit sogar auf dem Burger drauf.
Darf man das dann noch als
Hähnchen-Burger verkaufen?
Sowas sollte es deutschlandweit geben. Ich glaube, es
gibt so Sachen auch deutschlandweit.
Ich glaube, es gibt sowas deutschlandweit
sogar. So, so Meta,
Meta-Seiten dafür.
Muss nachher noch eine Runde rennen, Leute.
Ich war heute Vormittag nicht, also
beziehungsweise heute, heute, heute früh war ich
nicht. Habe lieber Stream angemacht.
Was ist denn heute dran?
28 Minuten
Recovery. Ja.
Okay.
Das werde ich heute
überleben.
28 Minuten Recovery. Easy.
Das ist ja gar nichts.
Alter, ich soll,
mit was soll ich rennen?
8 Minuten 10 pro Kilometer.
Das ist ja rückwärts gelaufen.
Ich hoffe mal, dass ein bisschen mehr
erlaubt ist noch, ja. Aber ich werde
erstmal Nudeln mit Lachs futtern dann.
Aber 8 Minuten 10
ist wirklich rückwärts, rückwärts laufen.
Ja. 8 Minuten 10
kann ich ja wirklich rückwärts laufen.
Also meine normale Base
Ausdauerläufe
sind mittlerweile so zwischen
6.30
und 7.
pro
Minuten pro Kilometer.
Laut Garmin.
Wenn ich
Was haben die so? Da gibt es ja noch
irgendwie so Schwellenausdauerläufe
oder so.
Die sind so bei 5.30, 5.45
und alles da drüber ist
bei Garmin meistens nur mit
wir rennen mal kurz
für
weiß ich nicht, eine Minute
4 Minuten
40 oder sowas.
Also mein Ziel ist ja
für die nächste Zeit
5 Kilometer unter 25 Minuten
Die Chancen,
dass ich das packe, jetzt schon
sind da.
Also ich kann schon
eine Weile unter 5 Minuten
laufen, aber das ist halt sehr anstrengend
und ich wollte mich da noch nicht durchquälen.
Mal gucken wie lange ich schaffe.
Ich werde das probieren, sobald
meine Garmin App sagt
die Garmin App hat nämlich so einen
Race Predictor dabei
und aktuell
sagt Garmin noch
dass ich
5.05
brauche.
Ja
und dann soll das mal
predicten.
Sobald es unter 5 Minuten predictet.
Ja mache ich.
Ich habe so einen auto-generated
Trainingsplan von Garmin.
Glaube ich zumindest, dass der auto-generated ist.
Der passt sich
auch an, wie gut man geschlafen hat und sowas.
Wie oft in der Woche? Jeden Tag?
Ja, mittlerweile bin ich
bei jedem Tag angekommen.
Jeden Tag, außer wenn
die Garmin App sagt, einen Tag ausruhen.
Das kommt manchmal vor.
So alle 14 Tage
oder 3 Wochen oder so, sagt es mal
das reicht jetzt ruhig mal einen Tag aus.
Aber jeden Tag
manchmal, manchmal ist es aber auch so
gerade wenn die Garmin App
meint, hier renn mal 10 km
und zwischendurch dann immer mal schnell
und sowas. Die haben teilweise richtig
anstrengende Trainingstage da drinnen.
Ähm, dass mir am
anderen Tag noch ein bisschen das Schienbein weh tut
dann gehe ich auch alternativ
mal eine Runde Fahrrad fahren.
Anstatt zu rennen. Das ist eh eine ganz gute
Abwechslung. Sobald man es in den Beinen merkt
einfach eine Runde Fahrrad fahren gehen.
So, ich muss mal kurz die Klimaanlage
anmachen. Alter hier ist irgendwie 29 Grad.
Oder so. Ne, 27.
27,1
ist es. Okay.
Bei welchem Coach
hast du das?
Bei irgendeiner Garmin AI.
So, was haben wir denn sonst noch?
Komm, ein Video können wir uns noch geben.
Ja, wir gucken uns noch das
Fireship Video an zu den neuen
Browser Wars.
Ne, also gut, das ist ja schon mal nicht so.
Also mindestens nicht auf Twitter.
...
besten entwickelt.
Mozilla hat ganz viel Zeug drumherum gemacht,
was nichts mit dem Browser
zu tun hatte. Und Firefox
war mal für mich so der
Hackerman-Browser schlechthin, wo mehr
möglich war als in allen anderen, auch was Plugins
angeht. Und ich finde, da hat
sich Mozilla ein bisschen entfernt
von die letzten Jahre über.
As a society, we can't
allow that to happen. And luckily, there's
someone actually doing something about it.
It is August 12, 2024, and you're
watching The Code Report.
Wenn ein Browser in Rust,
das war ja eigentlich nur
eine Frage, wenn ein Browser in Rust mal am Start ist.
Die Frage, was die unter der
Haube verwenden. Die werden bestimmt
nicht alles komplett neu in Rust
entwickelt haben, oder? Oder doch?
Mal gespannt.
Ist Firefox nicht schon in Rust?
Teile, Teile in Firefox sind in Rust.
Fisch,
Bärtsch,
für den Sub, massive subscription.
Servo Engine and Blitz,
a super minimal.
Erst mal Bezos überweisen, so ist das richtig.
But I want to talk about something even more ambitious.
A futuristic open source browser
called Ladybird. In October 2018
Andreas Kling, a software engineer
who worked on WebKit at Apple and Nokia,
had just gotten out of a three-month Swedish
rehab program and was unemployed and bored.
And when smart people like him get bored,
dann hat er sich gedacht, wird mal Zeit für einen neuen Browser.
and don't have access to drugs,
they start doing extreme things, like when
he built his own operating system to use as a
daily driver. That included a 1990s
GUI with a late 2000s Unix CLI.
Everything from the kernel to the web browser
had to be made from scratch. And this is
how Serenity OS was born, which is
named after the Serenity prayer.
God grant me the Serenity to accept the things
I cannot change, the courage to change the things
I can, and the wisdom to know the difference.
On July 4th, 2022,
the Serenity OS browser engine
declared its independence as a cross-platform
project. Now a full web browser,
it was renamed Ladybird. Over a thousand
contributors, half a million lines of
C++ code, and two years later,
Why does it always have to be C++?
Ja gut, weil viele Sachen schon fertig
in C++ sind, die man für Browser
verwenden kann. Das ist klar.
Der wird das nicht vom Scratch gebaut haben.
Und sonst wäre es in Rust.
What the fuck?
Over a thousand contributors, half a million
lines of C++ code, and two years
later, Andreas joined forces with one of the
GitHub co-founders to form a non-profit
to manage the browser. Believing the way
to not have bad incentives is to have
no incentives. The project is funded entirely
by sponsorships,
and donations, and most importantly,
the code is entirely free and won't borrow
from other browsers. And that's a big
contrast even to privacy-focused
browsers like Brave,
which is for profit and built
on top of Google's Chromium.
But speaking of tools that are free
and open source, another incredible
project you need to know about is
Convex, the one true Firebase
alternative and sponsor of today's
video. As an app developer, it allows
you to make one decision for your
backend. By providing scheduled jobs,
server functions, database queries,
and file storage, all in pure TypeScript.
And that gives us this beautiful TRCP-style
autocomplete and type safety across the
entire stack. In addition, Convex delivers
an ACID-compliant database with optimized
caching and optional schema enforcement,
but without the pain points of SQL.
Weil ich ja immer noch so ein
old-school-Kack-Noob bin und mir im
Zweifelsfall eine Linux-VM-Miete für
mein Backend.
... and ORMs. And like a true
Firebase alternative, you can get
automatic real-time subscriptions on
all database queries. Use the link on
the screen to build a project for free
right now. Seriously, Convex is an
awesome project, but now let's get back
to Ladybird and talk about the
disappointing part. The first alpha
version for Linux and macOS isn't
expected until the summer of 2026.
And you'll probably die of old age by
the time the Windows version comes out.
The good news is that you can play
around with the code and build it from
source on GitHub, but building a web
browser from scratch is extremely
complicated.
Die haben angekündigt, auf Swift zu
wechseln.
Zwift.
... complex. And the general consensus
is that it's impossible to pull off.
In order for web developers to build
websites with their half-assed HTML,
CSS, and JavaScript code, browser engines
need to follow the W3C spec, which
contains over 114 million words.
And it constantly evolves with new
features that raise the barrier to
entry. It's not a project you build in a
weekend by primting ChatGPT.
The developers have already built their
own HTML and JS engines, creatively
named LibHTML and LibJS, and are
leveraging established tools like
FFmpeg for videos. In software
development, the cycle goes from make
it work to make it good to make it
faster. And they're very much in phase
one of the cycle. Making a web browser
ain't easy, but it's honest work,
regardless of the market share...
Apple will weg von Zwift? Das kann ich mir
nicht vorstellen. Die haben doch letztens
erst was vorgestellt mit Zwift jetzt
auch für Microcontroller und sowas.
... the word gets, we all benefit from them
trying, because the consolidation of
power on the Internet is only getting
worse. And who knows, maybe one day, we'll be able to do that.
... and who knows, maybe one day, we'll be able to do that.
it'll be our last hope to smuggle dank
cat memes in and out of cyberspace this
has been the code report thanks for
watching and i will see you in the next
one
okay jetzt wissen wir bescheid ich dachte
eigentlich dass es hier eher so um
manifest v3 geht und dass sachen im
browser abgeschaltet werden was ja auch
demnächst auf uns zukommt und dann werde
ich einfach nur noch nur noch chromium
und firefox verwenden und nicht mehr
chrome
the world wide web is arguably
uns jetzt nicht das haben wir sonst
noch hier warum softwareentwicklung der
beste job ist kann sich jetzt darüber
streiten aber es ist auf jeden fall für
technik interessierte eine gute idee in
generell in der it zu arbeiten weil es
kohle bringt und das potenzial hat für
leute die sich dafür interessieren dass
man auch was macht was einem spaß macht
das ist natürlich eine gute kombination
so
also geld verdienen und spaß machen
natürlich macht nicht alles spaß 70
prozent mieten und sind los rumsitzt
macht keinen spaß aber die chancen sind
zumindest da ich hab was mitbekommen
dass irgendjemand was mit den
eintrittspesten gemacht hat und dann
rausgeschmissen wurde vom veranstalter
irgendwas habe ich da am rande mit
bekommen
aber genau weiß ich nicht irgendjemand
hat eine qr-code auf den ausweis gedruckt
oder so und dann das hat dem hat dem hat dem veranstalter nicht gefallen irgendwie
sowas in der richtung also das glaube ich nicht dass apple swift absägt wenn man was
ist die alternative wieder zurück zur objective c oder oder was die wollen ihren c code in rust
umwandeln ja das kann ich verstehen rust interop geht auch wunderbar mit anderen sprachen die haben
also das ist wieder was anderes das kenne ich das kenne ich nicht aber da war auch was mit den
pässen wo sie den typ rausgeschmissen haben die haben die hotels immer nach lötkolben und
raspberry pi sucht die leute herausgeworfen wie da brauche ich jetzt ein bisschen mehr kontext
warum ist es verboten bei irgendeiner hacker konferenz lötkolben und raspberry pi dabei zu
haben hätte ich hätte vermutet die leute die das nicht dabei haben sind verdächtiger so leute
package updates wir haben schon seit zwei stunden 54 minuten und 34 sekunden keine package updates
mehr gemacht mal gucken ob es neue gibt nein gibt es nicht aber das archlinux ich bin ein
teuer
warum gibt es keine neuen updates nach 4 nach zweieinhalb stunden arch by the way ich will
besonders bleeding edge sein weil man hacker da nicht haben wollte aber ist das nicht eine
hacker konferenz ich weiß gar nicht wo diese konferenz ist wahrscheinlich in usa irgendwo
ok kommt eine sache kommen so angucken was gucken wir uns mal an hier uns angucken warum
softwareentwicklung der beste job ist ok schnell beim stoffentwicklung der beste job ist ok schnell beim stoffentwicklung der beste job ist ok schnell beim
schnittrate겠지만 vor allem schnell durchgang was hat kevin zu berichten wenn es um
softwareentwicklung geht ich hoffe franz ist wieder mit dabei im video sag ich auch geil
oder das erste was man sich merkt ist das anicating hat mit der franz heißt damals ein
video vogelte war irgendwie in spanien hat dort irgendwie so eine regelung mit seinem
arbeitgeber getroffen ich darf irgendwie ein halbes jahr home office aus spanien machen und
Und dann ist er dann immer schön mit Franz mittags Gassi gegangen.
Das fand ich nice.
Vor langer Zeit, als ich angefangen habe, mich für den Beruf des Softwareentwicklers zu interessieren,
war einer der Gründe die hohen Gehälter.
Wisst ihr, wir sind mit ziemlich wenig Geld aufgewachsen.
Ganz ehrlich, ich kann jeden verstehen, der was machen will, wo es viel Kohle gibt.
Wir müssen alle gucken, wo wir bleiben.
Deswegen finde ich diese Fragen ja auch bei Vorstellungsgesprächen dann immer toll.
So, warum wollen Sie zu uns?
Ja, weil ich Geld verdienen will.
Weil ich nicht unter der Brücke schlafen will.
Natürlich kannst du das nicht sagen, sondern musst dir dann irgendwas aus den Fingern saugen.
Und natürlicherweise wollte ich es für meine eigene Zukunft und für meine zukünftige Familie natürlich besser haben.
Ja, das ist quasi so ein Überlebensinstinkt.
Aber nach über zehn Jahren in der Branche weiß ich, dass das Gehalt eigentlich nur Nebensache ist.
Alleine für das...
Ja, das sagen Leute, die First World Problems haben, so wie ich auch.
Wenn man genug Kohle verdient, dann kann man immer sagen,
Ja, ne, eigentlich ist das Gehalt ja Nebensache.
Wenn du am Ende des Monats Minus auf dem Konto hast, dann siehst du das wahrscheinlich ein bisschen anders.
Das Geld macht wahrscheinlich niemand diesen Job.
Also, ich bin mir darüber bewusst, dass ich mich da in einer sehr, sagen wir mal, First World Problems Situation befinde.
... dass das Gehalt eigentlich nur Nebensache ist.
Alleine für das Geld macht wahrscheinlich niemand diesen Job.
Und gerade Leute, die nicht als Softwareentwickler arbeiten, haben wahrscheinlich auch ein ziemlich verzerrtes Bild darüber, wie der Job in der Realität eigentlich ist.
Ja.
Aber wenn es...
Das denke ich, das glaube ich auch.
Ich glaube, die meisten Leute stellen sich unter Softwareentwickler vor, man macht den ganzen Tag das hier.
In Wirklichkeit macht man den ganzen Tag Google-Suche und dann das hier.
Und 60% Mieten.
Wenn es nur eine Regel gibt, an die ich mich für meinen Kanal und alle meine Videos halte, ist, dass ich einen realistischen Einblick in die Arbeit als Softwareentwickler geben möchte.
Klingt viel Kaffee.
Aber ich bekomme natürlich auch Feedback von anderen professionellen Softwareentwicklern, dass bei denen der Job komplett anders aussieht.
Und das glaube ich.
Das glaube ich auch.
Aber vielleicht habe ich auch einfach ein falsches Bild vermittelt, denn so wie ich arbeite, heißt es ja nicht, dass es eine allgemeingültige Antwort ist.
Es ist kein einfacher, gechillter Job, wo man einfach mal ein bisschen programmiert und am Ende des Monats ein fettes Gehalt überwiesen bekommt.
In der Realität ist es ein anstrengender, harter Job, bei dem kein Tag wie der andere ist.
Es gibt immer Situationen zum Haare raufen, Code, der nicht funktioniert, den du gar nicht angefasst hast, anstrengende Meetings und Diskussionen und Deadlines, die nur schwer einzuhalten sind.
Wenn du also ein...
Also ich kann sagen, ich bin zwar kein hauptberuflicher Softwareentwickler, aber da gibt es von mir auch durchaus Parallelen zu.
Wenn du einen einfachen Job haben willst, dann ist das mit Sicherheit nicht die beste Wahl für dich.
Ich überlege oft, wie es so wäre, wenn ich einen komplett anderen Job hätte, ich weiß nicht, irgendwas Handwerkliches, Schreiner oder so.
Denn ich sitze eigentlich...
Schreiner, sehr gut.
Was mit Holz?
Einzig Ware.
...den ganzen Tag mehr oder weniger isoliert, alleine von meinem Computer.
Also unabhängig davon, ob ich ins Büro gehe oder von zu Hause.
Also unabhängig davon, ob ich ins Büro gehe oder von zu Hause arbeite.
Und trotzdem bin und bleibe ich Softwareentwickler.
Aber wieso?
Es gibt für mich einen viel tiefer sitzenden Grund, wieso es ein wunderbarer Job ist und auch die Fähigkeit zu haben, etwas programmieren zu können.
Denn es ist einer der ganz wenigen Fähigkeiten, wo man aus praktisch nichts etwas Wertvolles erschaffen kann.
Anders als bei etwas Handwerklichem, wo man etwas Physisches erstellt, sind alle Bausteine, die du brauchst, um deine eigene Software zu programmieren, frei verfügbar.
Vielen sind sich dessen eigentlich gar nicht bewusst, aber wenn man diesen Fakt einmal verinnerlicht hat, dann ist es einfach übertrieben.
Das ist eigentlich dieser Moment, wenn du realisierst, dass du eigentlich nicht auf andere warten musst, um etwas umzusetzen, sondern du hast einen Laptop und hast damit eigentlich schon alle Kriterien erfüllt.
Du kannst einfach loslegen und dein komplettes Leben mit ein paar einfachen Skripten automatisieren.
Du kannst auf die...
Du kannst, wenn du kannst, kannst du, ja.
Und was prinzipiell dafür natürlich notwendig ist, du kannst, aber brauchst erstmal eine Idee.
Da scheitert es, glaube ich, bei vielen Leuten schon dran.
...dich zugeschnitten.
Du kannst damit eine Apps programmieren, die genau so funktionieren, wie du sie haben willst.
Du musst keine fertige Lösung benutzen, die mit...
Dann hast du aber das Problem, dass du die, wenn du eine App programmierst für iOS, die ohne Code-Signing und Apple, wie heißt das bei denen, Developer-Account, nicht auf dein Handy bekommst, weil die alle, glaube, sieben Tage oder zehn Tage wieder runterfliegt.
Aber das ist ja nur Nebensätze. Ich weiß, das ist nicht das, was er sagen will.
...all ihren Kompromissen kommt.
Es muss keine weltbewegende Sache sein, es reicht eine Kleinigkeit, die vielleicht ein Problem von dir oder sogar von vielen anderen Leuten löst.
Und vielleicht triffst du mit deinem...
Du brauchst keine paar tausend Euro Equipment vor der Nase, um was zu programmieren.
Du brauchst kein MacBook Pro oder sowas für 5000 Euro.
Du kannst dir einen Mini-PC kaufen für 300 Euro und einen Monitor, eine Tastatur, das reicht.
Also du kommst mit weit unter 1000 Euro hin, dir einen ordentlichen Arbeitsplatz rechnen.
...einer Lösung sogar einen Nerv und wirst dir irgendwann mal einen Haufen Kohle damit verdienen, falls du das möchtest.
Du kannst an einem Tag mit einer Idee und einem leeren Projekt starten und wachst ein paar Jahre später auf und bist einfach der Chef von einer großen, erfolgreichen IT-Firma.
Diese Möglichkeit alleine sind Gründe, wieso...
Das stimmt wohl. Wenn du da Bock drauf hast, wenn du das, wie heißt das, das Business Mindset hast und dich mit sowas beschäftigen willst, weil...
...mit Programmieren allein...
...wird das nix.
Das darf man ja nicht...
...sollte man jetzt auch erwähnen.
Du brauchst da schon eine ganze gehörige Portion, also wenn du von...
...ich programmier mein Projekt, ein paar Jahre später habe ich eine Firma, da gehört auch ganz viel Business und BWL und Krempel dabei.
Also als reiner...
...wenn du wirklich nichts anderes machst, als den ganzen Tag programmieren, dann wird das wahrscheinlich nix.
Wo ich das liebe, Software...
Also wirst früher oder später mal ein bisschen was machen müssen, worauf du keinen Bock hast.
...zu sein.
Es gibt praktisch kein Limit nach oben und überall um dich rum gibt es kostenlose Ressourcen, die dich auf deinem Weg unterstützen.
Ich kann dir eine Mini-App zeigen, an der ich aktuell wieder arbeite und die mich auch auf die Idee für dieses Video gebracht hat.
Ich könnte euch auch eine App, darf man das App nennen, was von mir zeigen, wo ich seit einem Jahr nichts mehr committet habe und 35 ungelöste GitHub-Issues habe.
Wie viele haben wir eigentlich gerade? Ich weiß es gar nicht.
So sieht es halt mit Motivation teilweise aus, ja.
Manchmal ist man super motiviert, wenn man was anfängt und danach hat man keinen Bock mehr.
Wie viele ungelöste GitHub-Issues haben wir eigentlich mittlerweile?
31. 31. Service not enabled.
Was? Was?
Keine Ahnung. Anwenderfehler.
Muss Anwenderfehler sein.
Ich bin sehr unmotiviert daran weiterzubauen.
Den VM-Champ, den werde ich sogar schneller fixen, weil der gerade kaputt ist.
Ich habe auch schon nachgeguckt, woran es liegt.
Das machen wir nachher.
Ich sage es mal nicht, aber das machen wir.
Es wird Zeit.
Ich bin der Überzeugung, dass Multitasking ein Mythos ist.
Wenn ich an einer Sache arbeite, kann ich dort nur gute Ergebnisse erzielen, wenn ich mich nicht von anderen Sachen ablenken lasse.
Es kommt es aber häufiger mal vor, dass ich mich mit einer Aufgabe beschäftige.
Das stimmt nicht nur dafür.
Ich habe laut meiner Garmin-Uhr heute nur einen Sleep-Score von 56 gehabt.
Von 100.
Das ist schlecht.
Ich glaube, das lag daran, weil ich einfach nachts über wieder das Handy habe laufen lassen mit YouTube-Zeug drauf und dabei gepennt habe.
Und dann eine Idee habe, die ich mir notieren muss.
Und genau dafür habe ich die Mac-App LittleNote programmiert.
Die Grundidee ist eigentlich wirklich ganz einfach.
Mit einer Tastenkombination kann ich ein kleines Notizfenster in den Vordergrund holen und eine kurze Notiz schreiben.
Deshalb auch LittleNote.
Danach verschwindet das Fenster.
Danach verschwindet das Fenster wieder und ich kann...
Gibt es nicht schon 30 Milliarden Apps, die sowas machen?
...meine Aufgabe weitermachen.
Die Tatsache, dass ich nicht aus dem Vollbildmodus meiner aktuellen Arbeit...
Ich darf ja nicht sagen, ich bastel auch an so kleinen Kram rum.
Ich sag nur hier...
Könnt ihr euch noch daran erinnern?
Das gab es hier standardmäßig nicht.
Wir haben dieses komische Timer-Widget hier programmiert im Stream.
Wo du dir so einen Kurzzeit-Weckersatz stellen kannst.
Und wie oft...
Also da haben wir ein, zwei Streams dran rumprogrammiert.
Und...
Und wie oft habe ich das jetzt schon benutzt?
Dreimal dürft ihr raten.
Ich dachte mir, das ist eine coole Idee.
Braucht man öfters?
Ja, gar nicht.
Ausbrechen hilft mir dabei, den Fokus nicht zu verlieren.
Eine super kleine App, die mir aber wahnsinnigen Mehrwert bietet.
Vielleicht gibt es auch schon ähnliche Apps, die allerdings nie so funktionieren, wie ich es mir gewünscht habe.
Das Problem kenne ich.
Also habe ich einfach meine Entwicklerfähigkeit...
Ich habe auch oft mal Sachen, die ich ausprobiere und denke, eigentlich eine coole Sache.
Aber irgendwie...
Aber irgendwie die Handhabung gefällt mir nicht.
Ja, das Problem kenne ich.
Benutzt, um eine erste Version der App zu programmieren, die danach auch schon funktioniert hat.
Seit der Veröffentlichung habe ich immer mehr Ideen bekommen, wie ich die App weiterentwickeln kann.
Und nach und nach werde ich Funktionen hinzufügen, damit LittleNote noch besser für mich arbeitet.
Ich muss zum Beispiel oft wissen, wie lang ein Text ist.
In der Vergangenheit habe ich immer so eine Word-Counter-Webseite benutzt.
By the way, Leute. WC-C.
Das muss ich ganz ehrlich sagen.
Das war immer ein bisschen nervig.
Deswegen habe ich einfach so einen Info-Button in meine LittleNote-App programmiert.
WC-C.
Damit ich einfach einen Text in meine App reinkopiere...
Stellt euch mal vor.
Wenn ich jetzt...
Wenn ich jetzt wissen...
Nein, die Wörter...
Die Buchstaben will er wissen.
Stellt euch mal vor.
Wenn ich jetzt wissen will, wie viele Buchstaben...
Wie viele Buchstaben hat meine Wimmer-C.
Und da sehe ich 1070.
Ach so, er will Wörter haben.
Kann man mit WC auch Wörter...
Ja, ja, hier.
Wörter.
Ja.
118.
Geht auch.
Also, easy.
Und dann wird mir angezeigt, wie lang der Text ist.
Würde ich eine frei verfügbare App benutzen, die diese...
So was wie WC, zum Beispiel.
WC-C ist Bytes, nicht Zeichen.
Das ist richtig.
Aber zu 99,9% ist ein Byte ein Zeichen.
... diese Funktion nicht hat, müsste ich wohl weiterhin die Wörter verwenden.
Das ist richtig.
Aber zu 99,9% ist ein Byte ein Zeichen.
Dass das jeder so machen muss.
Ist das nicht cool? Ich zeige dir gleich mal, woran ich als nächstes arbeiten werde.
Aber gerade wenn du alleine bist, hast du nicht die Kapazitäten, um alles selbst zu machen.
Und genau dafür gibt es bestehende Tools, die mich dabei unterstützen.
Dazu möchte ich dir heute Informaniak vorstellen. Das ist der ethische Cloud-Anbieter aus der Schweiz.
Die machen einfach alles anders, als man es sonst gewohnt ist.
Denn die legen ihren Fokus auf Dinge, die wir alle zu schätzen wissen.
Privatsphäre. Alle Dienste sind in der Schweiz in eigenen Datenzentren gehostet und sind komplett eigene Entwicklungen.
Okay. Ich kenne das Argument von vielen Anbietern, die sagen, aber wir machen Datenschutz richtig.
Und ich unterstelle den Anbietern auch gar nichts.
Ich glaube, viele Anbieter, guckt euch die ganzen VPN-Anbieter an, die sagen das ja auch.
Das Ding ist, warum ich finde, dass dieses Argument nicht zählt, ist, ich kann das nicht überprüfen, ob das stimmt.
Und ich muss diesem Anbieter vertrauen, dass alles richtig ist, was er sagt.
Und das ist halt die Frage, habe ich dieses Vertrauen gegenüber einem Anbieter, wo ich alle meine Daten hinschiebe.
Und nachdem ich selbst gut genug weiß, wie kompliziert das ist, Sachen, sagen wir mal, ordentlich zu betreiben, dass es keine Probleme gibt,
weiß ich nicht, ob ich den meisten Anbietern da traue.
Mit Ausnahme von Open-Source-Anwendungen, wo sie aber auch selbst Contributor sind.
Das Angebot ist wirklich vielfältig, denn sie bieten Hosting und Mailing an, aber auch ihre K-Suite.
Da ist dann an Funktionen alles dabei, von Chat, Cloud-Speicher, Kalender und alles, um gemeinsam an Dokumenten und Präsentationen zu arbeiten.
Eine Funktion, die ich unbedingt hervorheben möchte, ist...
Das ist genau das gleiche Problem, was ich auch mit VPN-Anbietern habe.
VPN kann schon was bringen.
Gerade für die klassische VPN-Anwendung.
Ich will mir irgendwo eine Linux-Distribution runterladen.
Natürlich, was sonst?
Und will nicht, dass jemand sieht, dass ich das runtergeladen habe.
Ja, okay, das ist okay, lasse ich mir alles gefallen.
Da kann das helfen.
Aber die ganzen Zusatzversprechen, die es da bei VPN-Anbietern gibt,
die sind entweder von Anfang an Blödsinn,
oder sie sind halt nur so lange gültig, wie ich irgendwie diesem VPN-Anbieter traue, alles richtig zu machen.
Und das mache ich halt nicht.
Da kannst du einfach bis zu 50 GB Daten verschicken.
Du kannst dir nicht vorstellen,
wie nützlich das in meinem Alltag ist,
denn ich muss regelmäßig ziemlich große Datenmengen an meinen Cutter schicken.
Das geht komplett ohne Anmeldung und die Daten bleiben 30 Tage verfügbar.
Die Daten bleiben in der Schweiz und Informaniac verdient daran auch kein Geld.
Im Gegenteil, aber sie nutzen es als Marketing für ihre Cloud- und Hosting-Anwendungen,
die wir uns beim nächsten Mal anschauen werden.
Schau auf jeden Fall mal bei Informaniac dabei und probiere mal Swiss Transfer aus.
Den Link dazu findest du unten in der Videobeschreibung.
Für meine Node-App habe ich aktuell keine Cloud-Anbindung.
Was ich allerdings ändern möchte, ist,
denn wenn mein Laptop kaputt geht, sind auch alle meine Notizen weg.
Daher plane ich jetzt auch eine Cloud-Anbindung.
Ist auch nur Sellout, ja und? So nicht schlimm.
Ich war auch noch nie in einer Wüste.
Wer weiß, der weiß.
Und wenn die Daten sowieso in der Cloud sind und meine App sowieso sehr minimalistisch ist,
würde ich sagen, ist jetzt auch ein guter Zeitpunkt, auch eine iPhone-App dafür zu programmieren,
damit die Daten dann zwischen iPhone und Mac synchronisiert werden.
Ab da wird es jetzt nervig komplex.
Unterwegs ist das praktisch.
Ich schreibe dann später an meinem iPhone eine Notiz, um dann später an meinem Mac daran zu arbeiten.
Die Idee dazu hatte nicht nur ich, sondern einige Nutzer haben das in den Vorschlägen kommentiert.
Und genau dafür habe ich ja Programmieren gelernt.
Wenn ich eine Idee habe oder etwas haben möchte, dann kann ich mich einfach selbst an meinen Schreibtisch setzen und das Ganze umsetzen.
Und genau daran werde ich heute arbeiten.
Erst mal die 100.000 Euro Kaffeemaschine am Start.
Niemand zwingt mich daran zu arbeiten.
Aber trotzdem hole ich mir einfach einen Kaffee und setze mich an die Arbeit.
Alle To-Dos für dieses Projekt organisiere ich sowieso immer in meinem Notion-Template.
Das hilft mir immer nur an einer Sache gleichzeitig zu arbeiten.
Chat, jetzt seid mal nicht so gemein.
Sellout unter YouTube-Videos ist doch überhaupt kein Ding.
Muss gucken, wo man bleibt.
...verarbeiten und nach jeder neuen Funktion ein App-Update zu veröffentlichen.
Immer stetig kleinere Verbesserungen an die Leute bringen.
Also du verstehst schon, kein Multitasking.
Ich fange erst mal mit der iCloud-Synchronisierung an.
Denn dieses Feature-Update ist eine sehr gute Möglichkeit, um die Leute zu verändern.
Alleine macht die App schon viel besser.
Da ich mich auch nicht mit allem auskenne, muss ich mich erst mal auch da reinfuchsen.
Ich bin doch kein Designer und daher arbeite ich erst mal an der Funktionalität, bevor ich es schöner mache.
Leider werden meine Apps nie richtig hübsch.
Das kann ich verstehen.
Ich bin ja auch der ausgesprochene CSS-Profi, wenn es um Design geht von irgendwelchen Web-Anwendungen.
Wobei ich muss zugeben, die Sache mit dem Web-Interface für den ESP32...
Wo man die WiFi-Credentials ändern kann über einen Browser und so.
Das sah doch ganz okay aus, oder?
Ich meine, das sind Tailwind-Standardfarben, die ich da verwende, die drin sind.
Aber das sah schon ganz brauchbar aus.
Nicht ganz so hässlich wie meine Web-Anwendungen früher.
Deshalb schaue ich mich für die iPhone-App mal um, wie das Design für diese App sein könnte.
Komplett fertig wird die App sowieso nicht, aber umso mehr Fortschritte ich mache, desto besser.
In den nächsten Videos kann ich dort auch mal gerne ein bisschen mehr ins Detail gehen.
Um das nicht zu verpassen, lasst auf jeden Fall mir hier kostenlos ein Abo da.
Da kannst du sicherlich einiges lernen.
Moment, was ist das? Das muss ich mir nochmal angucken.
Aha.
Boah, das ist ja Screen-Overload.
Ich meine, jeder das ans Setup, was er mag.
Aber mir wäre es zu viele Bildschirme.
Ein iPad oben?
Oder das ist doch nicht mal ein iPad.
Das ist irgendwie ein Alexa-Ding oder sowas vielleicht, hä?
Keine Ahnung.
Und dann hier unten das Ding.
Also, ich meine, okay, so viel anders ist es bei mir jetzt auch nicht.
Sieht bloß nicht so schön aus.
Ich habe hier den Monitor, den ihr jetzt seht.
Links den Monitor daneben.
Und aktuell zwei iPhones auf dem Tisch liegen.
Zwei iPhones, weil mein privates und das von der Firma.
Und manchmal habe ich tatsächlich auch noch ein iPad.
Das ist mein Klo-iPad.
Ich habe ja ein extra Lese-iPad fürs Klo.
Aber manchmal gucke ich da drauf was und nehme es dann mit rüber und lasse es irgendwie noch fertig laufen.
Oder habe da was aufgemacht, was ich da noch brauche.
Aber im Prinzip ist so ein großer Unterschied ist es nicht.
Man muss aber sagen, dass es bei ihm deutlich ordentlicher und aufgeräumter und stylischer aussieht als bei mir.
Ja, also den Mixer habe ich tatsächlich auch mehr oder weniger an der gleichen Stelle liegen.
Aber mein Schreibtisch sieht...
Das sieht nicht so stylisch aus.
Die Funktion der MacOS und der iPhone.
Ich habe kein GoXLR, ich habe einen Moto Track 16.
Das ist ein Audio Interface, das habe ich schon über zehn Jahre.
Ja, das Teil habe ich schon ganz lang.
Und das funzt halt einfach auch.
App sollen praktisch identisch sein, daher ist es sinnlos alles doppelt zu programmieren.
Das ist keine Schreibtischlampe, das ist für Videoaufnahmen so ein Beleuchtungsding.
Deshalb baue ich meinen Code jetzt so um, dass ich geteilte Komponenten habe, die von beiden Apps benutzt werden können.
Die Vorteile sind, dass ich weniger Code warten muss und neue Funktionen schneller hinzufügen kann.
Denn so entwickle ich sie nur einmal und kann sie für beide Plattformen auf einmal aktivieren.
Bei dem Umbau kann auch einiges kaputt gehen, deshalb arbeite ich wie immer mit Git und GitHub.
Nur um sicher zu gehen, dass ich immer auf einen funktionierenden Stand zurück kann.
Ich habe große Pläne, dieses Projekt voranzutreiben.
Und meine Ideenliste wird auch immer länger.
Vielleicht ist ja auch was Nützliches für dich dabei.
Falls nicht, hast du die Möglichkeit, nur mit einem Laptop die Lösung für deine Probleme selbst zu programmieren.
Meine Schritte und Vorgehensweise, eine neue App von Grund auf zu programmieren, habe ich in diesem Video gezeigt.
Schau es dir gerne mal als nächstes an.
Ansonsten würde ich sagen, wir sehen uns beim nächsten Mal.
Dein Kevin.
Oh,Really?
Okay, dasührer drüben.
Guckst du halt immer wieder auf deinem Fanpage?
Nein, werde es dir auch mal weiterleiten.
Entschuldige, dass du dich vom соответhech nicht beteiligst.
begrüßen dich,osely liefern, files usd aufrufen.
Weiß der advanced ed setup jetzt echt?
Nein, als ich meine contradicte pairs, was wir imitta?
Kannst du das vorgelesen.
Ja nun tone und herein.
Dücks in den DES ein.
Spérience nicht highlight ist kein Ding.
Kommt euch 안 animat心 себе an theatre💥arte speeds impedimento🆂 player?
an Möbeln gekratzt oder ich habe es nie mitgekriegt.
Ey, F-Programmer, du hast recht.
Bevor ich auf gehe und weil wir uns ein Katzenvideo angeguckt haben, ich habe die News gelesen bei mir hier in der lokalen Zeitung,
dass ein Tierheim bei mir in der Nähe
eine Katze abgeliefert bekommen hat oder eine Katze aufgenommen hat mit zwei gebrochenen Beinen, nämlich hier rechte Beine, linke und hinten links.
Und Sammy kann aktuell nicht mehr laufen.
Und die brauchen 2.000 Euro für die Operation.
Das heißt, wenn einer von euch zuguckt und ein Herz für Sammy hat, ich poste es nochmal in den Chat,
die freuen sich sicherlich und Sammy freut sich auch.
Ich hoffe, wir kriegen das zusammen. Ich habe denen eine E-Mail geschrieben.
Und mal gucken, wenn die darauf antworten.
Wenn die darauf antworten, dass, keine Ahnung, noch irgendwie 500 Euro fehlen oder so,
dann bezahle ich die letzten 500 Euro.
Weil ich will, dass Sammy nicht mehr da ist.
Weil ich will, dass Sammy wieder laufen kann.
Man kann auch bei Paypal spenden, by the way. Ich habe das erst übersehen.
Sonst, weil hier auf direkte Überweisung habe ich immer keinen Bock.
Aber man kann auch bei Paypal spenden.
Also, wenn einer möchte, dass Sammy wieder laufen kann
und ein paar Euro übrig hat, jeder Euro hilft da.
Generell haben ja so Tierheime und Tierschutzwände immer keine Kohle.
Also, ich werde auf jeden Fall nächste Woche was spenden, wenn noch was auf ist.
Da kann Sammy operiert werden.
Und Sammy kann wieder laufen.
Haben wir noch was Gutes getan heute, Leute.
Ich gehe jetzt was futtern.
Der ist auch erst drei Jahre alt, ja.
Der hat sein Leben noch vor sich.
Ich gehe jetzt was essen.
Wir hören uns.
Macht's gut. Bis denn.
See you.